[Musique]
François Dupid Francis Dupidéri,
bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. On vous reçoit dans le
cadre de votre activité de professeur en
sciences politiques à l'univers de
recevoir
à l'université de Québec.
Université de Québec à Montréal. Québec
à Montréal.
Ucam
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ou compléter votre
présentation ?
Oui, donc c'est ça. Je suis professeur
de sciences politiques là-bas depuis
depuis 2006. Je travaille principalement
sur travaille en terme de recherche,
c'est-à-dire et d'enseignement sur la
démocratie, les mouvements sociaux, y
compris l'anarchisme et la répression
policière puisque généralement les
mouvements sociaux sont
la cible de répression policière. Donc
quand on s'intéresse aux mouvements
sociaux, on la voit bien. Et puis j'ai
travaillé aussi de sur un autre axe de
recherche sur les questions de
l'anttiféminisme
et un peu sur les questions de
démocratie.
Démocratie, c'est c'est le thème c'est
le thème majeur disons qui qui englobe
tout ça. Et puis aussi, j'ai une
peut-être un peu moins maintenant mais
j'essayais d'avoir une pratique
militante aussi quand même. Donc dans ce
qu'on appelait le mouvement alteralis
par exemple.
Et ben on va commencer tout de suite
avec les répression policières et les
mouvements sociaux. Comment ça se
matérialise ? Est-ce qu'il y a des
techniques de contre-insurrection ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des techniques
éprouvées ? Est-ce qu'il y a un petit
manuel de contre-insurrection qui est
élu par les États ? Alors euh très
certainement, il y a des il y a des
transformations. Les les forces
policières là, je vais je vais rester je
vais rester en Occident, disons, parce
qu'évidemment, il y a d'autres contextes
où il y a d'autres choses qui se passent
puis euh des fois c'est l'armée
d'ailleurs qui intervient, pas seulement
pas seulement la police, mais pour ce
qui est de pour ce qui est des forces
policières occidentales, clairement
depuis une trentaine d'années, à peu
près tout le monde se s'entend pour dire
qu'il y a eu des transformations
importantes et pas nécessairement très
positifes pour les mouvements sociaux
d'ailleurs euh au niveau des forces
policières. Et donc euh généralement, on
on s'entend pour dire que dans les
années euh disons post 68 aux États-Unis
aussi où il y a eu d'énormes mouvements
sociaux, c'est peut-être moins connu en
France, euh mais entre autres le black
power, le mouvement de la jeunesse, ce
mouvement contre la guerre du Vietnam,
dans les années 60, c'était il y a eu
des émeutes dans des quartiers
afro-américains, des fois qui duraient
plusieurs jours avec des dizaines de
morts. C'était extrêmement violent. Euh
les morts étaient du côté de la
population. Euh et évidemment en Europe,
il y a eu aussi euh des mobilisations
très très dure et très revendicatrices
et très turbulentes en France, mais en
Italie, en Allemagne et cetera. Et donc
euh la police la police était évidemment
appelée pour pour réprimer tout ça. Euh
mais leur moyens leur moyen d'action
avait pour effet que du côté de
l'opinion public, ça donnait pas
toujours les très belles images à la
télévision euh parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'attaques au corps. On utilise
souvent la matraque, par exemple, la
charge avec matraque et il y a eu
quelques moments célèbres qui ont été
des sortes de désastres médiatiques pour
la police comme des manifestations
contre à Chicago, contre la convention
du Parti démocrate où en fait des jeunes
des jeunes étudiants blancs radicaux
d'extrême gauche se faisaient matraquer
avec le visage en sang et se faisait
matraquer par des policiers. Donc tout
ça, ça donnait pas une très bonne très
bonne image de la police. Et donc c'est
à ce moment-là que dans les années 7080
des firmes de d'armement en fait ont
commencé à développer ce qu'on appelle
dans un sorte de d'uphémisme de
marketing d'uphémisme
les armes non létales qui sont en fait
évidemment tout ce qui est gaz
lacrymogène, balles de caoutchou, il y a
différents termes selon les pays là mais
canon à ultrason. canon ultrason, canon
à eau. Euh et et l'objectif évidemment
c'était de dire il faut créer une
distance, il faut être capable de mat
euh la turbulence, la foule, mais en
gardant tout le temps le plus possible,
pas tout le temps, mais le plus possible
une distance. Et euh selon le principe
que pour des raisons euh de perception
en fait, parce que c'est vraiment une
question de perception, euh le gaz
lacrymogène ou le canon à eux, ça semble
moins violent qu'un coup de matraque et
la balle de caoutchou, ben son avantage,
c'est qu'on la voit pas. euh elle va
elle va trop vite. Donc l'œil ne la
capte pas, mais évidemment la balle de
caoutchou, elle peut capter l'œil
évidemment euh et l'arracher.
Et donc il y a eu tout ça qui a été mis
en place dans les années 80 90 et en
Europe plus particulièrement, c'est
important de le souligner, dans les
années 80 90, il y a eu le fameux
phénomène des Holy Gans qui est pas
explicitement politique évidemment, on
peut en faire une analyse politique de
ce mouvement des Higans, mais qui a posé
des problèmes, disons, pour le dire
comme ça, en terme de maintien de
l'ordre pour les forces policières
européennes qui ont mis en place des
stratégies de coopération transnational
euh des périmètres de sécurité, des
zones interdites au rassemblement, des
contrôles au déplacement transfrontalier
qui part dans les autobus qui arrive à
tel endroit ou dans les trains. Et donc
par exemple, je donne des exemples, la
police française regardait qui partaient
des supporters de telle équipe qui se
rendaient à Liverpool par exemple et
informai les policiers anglais que tel
groupe arrivé à telle heure avec telle
personne et cetera.
Ça ça a été développé pour contrer le
phénomène des Higans. Mais c'est
quelques années après qui est apparu le
mouvement al celui qu'on appelait le
mouvement alter mondialiste qui
évidemment avait un autre sens politique
mais qui curieusement avait certaines
similarités.
Dans le mouvement intermondialiste, les
les lieux de mobilisation étaient
souvent les fameux sommets
internationaux et donc en fait il y
avait des déplacements qui évidemment
c'était pas pour aller au sport mais qui
pouvaient ressembler au même type de
déplacement. On louait des autobus, on
louait des trains, des ferries dans
certains cas, on allait dans l'autre
ville et on voulait se rassembler. Et
comme pour les Higans, l'objectif
l'objectif des Higans n'était pas
nécessairement de rentrer dans le stade
mais de trouver le bar ou le pob des
ennemis. Dans le cas du mouvementaliste,
évidemment, on ne pouvait pas être
invité à la à la table des 7 ou des 20
ou des du de l'OTAN, par exemple, mais
c'était de se retrouver dans dans une
ville et de d'aller à l'affrontement
symbolique ou physique contre contre
contre le sommet. Et donc ils ont
vraiment fait basculer les techniques
policières de la lutte contre le
higanisme à la lutte contre
l'altermondialisme avec vraiment des
techniques très similaires avec des
collaborations entre polices, des zones
interdites de de manifest de
manifestation, des périmètres de
sécurité, l'utilisation d'hélicoptères,
les fouilles dans le transport, euh
l'interdiction aussi pour certains
militants militantes de de se déplacer,
les écos téléphonique,
les échos téléphoniques et cetera. Et
puis là, on a ajouté évidemment les
arrestations de masse euh et cetera.
Donc et puis tout ça et c'est accompagné
d'une deuxième strate si on peut dire ça
comme ça de suréquipement de la police.
Et donc là on est passé aussi à ce qu'on
a appelé la militarisation de la police.
Donc là c'est pas seulement qu'ils ont
des nouveaux jou comme des des balles de
caoutchou et des gaz lacrirymogènes.
Vous les voyez là maintenant, ils sont
dans les années 70, si vous regardez des
images de d'affrontement par exemple,
même les mes 68, ils ont des sortes de
vareuse imperméable, mais aux
États-Unis, vous les voyez souvent en en
chemise
à manche courte en fait. Ils ont
peut-être un casque mais ils sont ils
sont en chemise et en pantalon de ville.
Euh maintenant, c'est vraiment moi, je
les compare souvent à des chevaliers euh
qui combattent dégueux et c'est vraiment
dégueu parce que en face, c'est des gens
qui sont habillés en coton euh peut-être
avec des bâtons, avec un foulard, avec
une casquette et cetera, mais
l'équipement est totalement
disproportionné entre les deux entre les
deux forces et la police maintenant, ce
sont des chevaliers en terme de en terme
d'équipement. Ils sont ça c'est ça la
militarisation de la police.
Vous avez étudié le matériel ? Est-ce
que le matériel a été designé pour que
l'aspect humain du policier soit caché
derrière le casque, derrière sa visière
? Alors, je pourrais pas dire ça avec
euh avec assurance, mais ce qui est
totalement euh euh pitoyable, c'est
qu'il y a des il y a des exemples. Euh
bon, ça date un peu, mais d'après moi,
on pourrait trouver des exemples plus
récents, mais au sommet des Amériques,
par exemple, on est en avril 2001, c'est
un sommet international pour négocier un
un marché communicain. Il y avait 34
chefs d'État, sauf un, Cuba,
la Lenard, non
et non, c'était c'était la ZLEA qui qui
s'est jamais réalisé en fait. Après ça,
ils ont fait des accords bilatéraux. Euh
donc, il y avait 34 chefs d'état qui
étaient dans la ville de Québec. C'était
à l'époque de la grande époque de
l'altermondialisme. C'était un an et
demi à peu près après Seattle et
quelques semaines avant la les fameuses
manifestations à gène contre le G8 qui
ont été extrêmement violentes où la
police a tiré à bout portant et a tué un
manifestant. Euh et donc et donc
et donc à Québec, la compagnie qui
produisait l'équipement euh
l'exosquelette de de protection des
policiers avait envoyé des observateurs
de sa compagnie pour voir l'efficacité
de l'équipement et sur leur site
internet, ils ventaient en fait les
actions policières lors du sommet des
Amériques comme preuve de la qualité de
leur équipement alors qu'un manifestant
avait eu le le l'arin cassé que il y
avait avait eu des centaines de
personnes arrêtées, que les gens avaient
eu des des membres fracturés, la
répression du mouvement devenait un
argument de vente pour l'équipement
policier.
Un peu comme Michel Alumari qui prend un
Vous connaissez Michel Alumari ? C'est
une politicienne française qui a été ou
tout à fait. En Tunisie, non, c'est pas
exactement. Elle vendait le matériel,
elle ventait et vendait du matériel
français si je me trompe pas.
Exactement.
Pour la police tunisienne. Ouais.
Euh revenons à nos moutons. Euh
un mouvement social qui est encadré, je
mets ça entre guillemets par les forces
de l'ordre. Euh vous avez une vous avez
vu une augmentation de ce type
d'encadrement, une augmentation des
mouvements sociaux. Est-ce que vous avez
vu une dynamique s'accélérer dans le
monde occidental ? la contestation, la
révolte
euh dans en fait, il y a comme deux
question il y a deux questions sur
l'encadrement et la l'encadrement, il
est tout le temps là depuis 100 150 ans
en fait, j'imagine depuis toujours, les
autorités politiques et économiques ont
voulu comme encadrer, il y a il y a
différentes techniques, hein. La police,
c'est la plus la plus bête, mais c'est
souvent la première la première
réplique.
Et d'ailleurs,
ça montre bien que qu' a une sorte de
boîte à outil du contrôle et de la
discipline et de la répression parce que
pendant quelques quelques temps, surtout
dans les universités, dans les années
7080 avec ce qu'on a appelé le
post-modernisme, fouo et cetera, on
disait bon ben en fait cette forme de de
domination du haut vers le bas avec
l'État régalien qui domine la société,
ça c'était l'époque moderne mais
maintenant on est dans le
post-modernisme et donc maintenant c'est
des stratégies de contrôle réticulaires
de on intègre nous-même les normes et on
s'autodiscipline et cetera. Moi je pense
qu' en fait les deux les deux les deux
continuent, les deux sont amalgamés,
fusionnés et la preuve c'est que la
police est le bon vieux coup de bâton.
Il est il est il est encore là. Mais
évidemment, il y a d'autres moyens de
contrôler un mouv un mouvement social,
de le diviser, de cooter ses leaders de
trouver des chefs pour les leur proposer
de rentrer dans le système.
Comment on fait ? Hm.
Comment on fait ?
Mais c'est ça, c'est ça. On
on influence l'opinion publique par les
médias, on influence
Ah ben il y a les mé les médias sont
tous les médias nécessairement sont là.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y
a même des des des stratégies des
stratégies plus euh
insidieuses de pénétration,
d'infiltration des mouvements de
l'intérieur.
Non, en fait c'est pas c'est pas tant
qu'ils infiltrent c'est pas tant qu'ils
infiltrent le mouvement, c'est qu'il
proposent au mouvement de s'intégrer aux
règles du jeu. Et donc comme ça, il le
il le pacifie, il le discipline. et
certains leaders des mouvements tendent
eux-mêmes à sentir le besoin de
discipliner ou de rejeter en fait les
franges les plus turbulente parce qu'en
fait ils veulent donner une image
respectable
légale de leur mouvement et d'eux-même
aux autorités pour être des
interlocuteurs légitimes et se retrouver
à la autour de la table. Et des fois les
élites politiques le demandent
explicitement. Elle demande à des
mouvements dénoncer la violence,
expulser les casseurs, les fameux
casseurs, organiser votre propre service
d'ordre. Et donc tout ça c'est des
stratégies de division, de contrôle et
cetera où là on demande à des mouvements
de de s'autodiscipliner, d'autoexclure,
d'automarginaliser
et vous allez avoir des porte-paroles
autoproclamés de mouvement qui vont même
dire ces gens ne n'appartiennent pas à
notre mouvement comme si c'était leur
mouvement qu'ils en étaient
propriétaires qui on qui mettaient une
clôture autour et qui disait "Vous, vous
êtes vous êtes des sortes de euh ça a
déjà été dit au sujet des fameux black
block, vous êtes les cancers du
mouvement, vous êtes vous venez
intoxiquer le mouvement, vous venez vous
infiltrer dans le mouvement alors
qu'évidemment ils sont dans le mouvement
aussi. À la limite, ils sont même plus
dans le mouvement que le porte-parole
quoi. Et est-ce que de lors de vos
études, de vos recherches, est-ce que
vous avez entendu parler de la notion de
agent perturbateur, argent provocateur ?
Ah ben bien sûr, ben pas juste dans pas
juste dans mes recherches, dans les
romans, dans dans les films, dans la
Oui, il y a des ça il y a toujours eu
ça. Il y en a encore, c'est sûr.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? c'est quand les
policiers soit soit que ce sont des
policiers euh qui infiltrent le
mouvement, soit que ce sont des gens qui
sont payés d'une manière ou d'une autre,
hein. Des fois, c'est pas juste en
argent, des fois c'est en remise de
peine ou des choses comme ça. Euh des
gens qui sont euh utilisés par la
police, disons, pour euh pour agir dans
un mouvement et euh généralement le le
pousser à prendre des risques et à mener
des actions qui veulent vulnérabiliser.
Et donc euh des exemples.
Oui, je donner des exemples. Bien sûr.
Tout à fait. Euh
euh euh
par exemple, je donner un exemple très
précis, peut-être trop anecdotique même,
mais je reviens au fameux sommet des
Amériques à Québec en en 2001 parce
qu'on un exemple bien documenté parce
qu'évidemment, il y a beaucoup de
théories paranoïqu au sujet des
provocateurs aussi, mais il y a il y a
des camps où on le sait parce qu' il y a
eu un procès donc c'est ces policiers là
qui qui se faisaient passer pour des
manifestants sont venus témoigner. Donc
là, on est comme là, ça s'en est. Et
donc avant le sommet des Amériques,
c'est un grand une grande mobilisation
contre un sommet. Donc il y a eu des
mobilisations pendant des mois et donc
il y avait des groupe qui s'organisaient
qui voulit qui voulait aller à Québec de
Montréal par exemple qui voulait aller à
Québec qui avait commencé à préparer bon
qui a une voiture qui qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire est-ce qu'on va est-ce qu'on va
arriver avec des bannières avec des
tambours, avec des trompettes, est-ce
qu'on va avoir des pinces pour passer à
travers la la clôture et cetera ? Et
donc à Montréal, il y a
des militants militantes qui se sont qui
ont vu des annonces d'emploi
pour je pense là, je me rappelle plus
mais je pense c'était pour une petite
compagnie de déménageurs. Je pense
c'était quelque chose de très pas très
compliqué. Ils sont allés voir les les
types et les types en fait avaient des
t-shirts euh je pense c'était fuck le
capitalisme, fuck le sommet ou quelque
chose comme ça. Donc clairement, ils
avaient l'air sympathique et donc ils
sont ils sont devenus euh ils sont
devenus amis et euh finalement ces gens
leur ont fourni du matériel euh entre
autres du matériel militaire. C'était en
fait des bombes fumigèes. C'était pas
rien de très dangereux mais c'était
quand même du matériel militaire. Donc
c'est c'est un crime relativement grave
de d'avoir accès du matériel du
militaire et l'utiliser. Ils leur ont
aussi fourni voiture pour se rendre à
Québec et donc sur le chemin vers
Québec, ils ont été interceptés, ils ont
été arrêtés. Et au procès, on a compris
qu'en fait les deux types, c'étaient des
agents de la gendarmerie royale du
Canada. C'était des policiers en
fonction. Euh la voiture c'était la leur
évidemment, ils avaient informé la
police et ces ces personnes ont passé
euh plusieurs mois en prison puis ont eu
des condamnations assez assez assez
importante. Et c'est de la provocation
parce qu'en fait sans cette sans cette
proposition, ces militants militantes en
fait n'avaient pas accès à cet
équipement et c'était même pas
nécessairement ça exactement qu'il
voulait faire. Il voulait faire quelque
chose en fait d'un peu moins dangereux
pour utiliser un terme qui est peut-être
pas qui est peut-être pas juste. Donc ça
c'est un exemple clair de provocation.
C'est un peu comme le le FBI qui incite
les les apprentis djihadistes à
djihadistes. C'est ça on leur fou.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Et puis vous pouvez avoir
des situations où dans telle ou telle
manifestation, la police peut trouver
avantageux par exemple que des vitrines
soient cassées et donc ça va être la
faire
soit qu'il laissent faire soit que soit
qu'ils utilisent des soit qu'ils
utilisent réellement des agents pour
pour eux-mêmes attaquer leur propre
voiture ou et cetera. Le problème, c'est
que une fois qu'on a dit ça, il y a il y
a il y a une il y a il y a une tentative
chez certaines personnes de penser que à
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque
chose, c'est tout le temps la police qui
contrôle, qui manipule, que le black
block c'est la police, que X c'est la
police, que Y c'est la police. Alors
qu'en fait dans la réalité, il y a les
deux choses qui qui vivent ensemble et
qui ont pas nécessèrement la même
logique mais qui peuvent prendre la même
force. La police à certains moments peut
avoir un avantage tactique disons ou
médiatique à ce que ça à ce que ça pète
si je peux utiliser cette expression.
Mais ça veut pas dire que le black block
travaille pour la police parce que le
black block lui peut aussi avoir ses
propres calculs et se dire que c'est
avantageux d'attaquer une banque,
d'attaquer une vitrine de de firme
d'intérim ou de ou une vitrine de
McDonald. Donc les deux peuvent avoir le
même objectif mais évidemment pour des
raisons tout à fait différentes.
Je sais pas si c'est clair là.
Si si si.
Euh est-ce qu'on peut parler de la
démocratie ?
J'espère.
Ça vous fait penser à quoi démocratie ?
C'est un mot qui galvodé ? C'est un mot
qui a été travesti, c'est un mot qui est
incompris ?
Alors euh
il va falloir m'arrêter parce que je
peux en parler pendant des heures et des
et des jours, mais là je vais commencer
quand même.
Est-ce que la démocratie c'est du
marketing pour les pauvres ? Alors, le
mot démocratie, c'est du marketing. Euh,
en fait, c'était le travail, si je peux
me permettre, là c'est pas très
important, mais c'était le travail de ma
thèse qui est devenu un livre après là,
démocratie, histoire, politique d'un
mot. Et euh et dans ce dans ce dans ce
livre euh ce que j'ai essayé de montrer
en fait, je recommence ce que j'ai
essayé de de démontrer en fait moi-même
j'avais un un questionnement ou un
étonnement, c'est que j'étais tombé sur
des livres d'autres auteurs, des
historiens ou d'autres euh pour la
France et pour les États-Unis qui
montraient très bien que ceux qu'on
appelle les pères fondateurs de nos
démocraties modernes, donc en France
évidemment les Républicains de la
révolution de 1789, Robespèpierre,
Danton et cetera B
par exemple et aux États-Unis ça va être
Washington, les frères Adams et
d'autres. En fait, dans les deux cas,
quand on retourne à leur au textes de
l'époque, donc soit leur déclaration,
leur manifestes, leurs lettres
personnelles, même dans leurs journaux
personnels, les textes dans les
journaux, les déclarations publiques et
cetera, dans les meetings ou dans des
assemblées, en fait, ce qui est très
bizarre que ils n'utilisent soit jamais
le mot démocratie pour parler de ce
qu'ils sont sont en train de faire ou de
leur projet ou quand ils l'utilisent,
c'est péjoratif. La démocratie, ça
évoque pour eux euh d'un point de vue
péjoratif, ça évoque le chaos. Euh ça
évoque la turbulence, l'instabilité,
l'égalité économique, ce qui est
péjoratif pour eux. On pourrait penser
que c'est positif, mais pour eux c'est
c'est scandaleux. Et puis euh ça c'est
d'un point de vue normatif et d'un point
de vue descriptif pour eux la démocratie
ça représente ça évoque toujours Athène.
Ils n'ont que ce modèle en tête parce
qu'en fait ils ont été éduqués
en lisant des classiques, en lisant
tuidide ou des auteurs classiques de
Rome ou de de
Athènes. Ils ont même appris l'histoire
de Spart parce qu'ils ont une éducation
classique. Certains d'entre eux même
parlent un peu le latin et le grec. Et
donc quand on parle quand eux parlent de
démocratie
en au 18e siècle, ils n'ont qu'Atin en
tête. Et en plus c'est péjoratif puisque
ce sont les pauvres, c'est la
turbulence, c'est c'est lesgux, c'est le
chaos, c'est la violence, c'est le c'est
le meurtre de mars de riches par exemple
et cetera. Et donc nos nos fameux pères
fondateurs,
ils ne disent ils ne disent jamais
qu'ils sont en train de fonder une
démocratie. Ils ne disent jamais qu'ils
sont démocrates. En fait, ils se font
accusés d'être démocrates par les
monarchistes pour les discréditer. Et
ils répliquent aux monarchistes, ils
disent "Non, non, nous ne sommes pas
démocrates." En fait, rapidement, ils
vont commencer à dire "Nous sommes
républicains et ils vont dire les
démocrates en fait c'est eux." Et eux,
c'est qui ? C'est dans le cas de la
Révolution française, par exemple, ceux
qu'on va appeler les enragés. Donc des
mouvements populaires qui sont dans la
grande turbulence de la révolution mais
qui ont des revendications beaucoup plus
radicales que l'Assemblée nationale. Euh
en terme économique par exemple, en
terme de participation euh directe de la
population, ils veulent que le pouvoir
reste dans ce qu'ils appelaient les
sections, c'est-à-dire les assemblées de
quartiers par exemple. Euh certains vont
proner ce qu'ils vont appeler le
fédéralisme qui est considéré comme un
crime de crime absolu pour les
Républicains qui veulent un système
centralisé. Mais en fait, le fédéralisme
était aussi quelque chose de de plutôt
contestataire à l'époque. Euh et donc
même s'il y avait aussi des
conservateurs qui le proposaient et donc
euh et donc ça c'est du côté de la
France, c'est du côté des des États-Unis
qui sont en fait encore à ce moment-là
les colonies britanniques. On a le même
scénario. On a des pères fondateurs qui
sont antidémocrates et qui disent les
démocrates c'est les mouvements
populaires turbulents, incontrôlables et
nous on est respectable, on est
raisonnable, on veut simplement une
République.
Et il y a il y a un autre une autre
raison pourquoi il ils disent cela,
c'est que dans le cas de la France, mais
dans le cas des États des colonies
britannique aussi, la plupart des fameux
pères fondateurs,
ils font partie des élites
intellectuelles ou politiques ou
économique ou si c'est pas eux, c'est
leurs frères ou leurs cousins ou leurs
voisins. C'est souvent des juristes et
ils sont souvent déjà membres
d'institutions
comme les États généraux mais évidemment
qui ça faisait longtemps qu' n'avaient
pas été convoqués mais les États
généraux. Donc il y a déjà cette cette
assemblée qui va s'appeler l'Assemblée
nationale très bientôt. Et puis dans les
colonies britanniques, ce que moi je
savais pas quand j'ai commencé à faire
ma recherche, c'est qu'il y avait des
assemblées coloniales, les sortes de
protoparlements dans les colonies qui
évidemment avaient pas tous les pouvoirs
par définition mais la plupart des pères
fondateurs, ils siègent déjà dans ces
dans c'est déjà des sortes de
parlementaires ou de députés.
Et donc quand ils font la fameuse
révolution pour la France ou
l'indépendance pour les les colonies
britanniques, ils veulent pas donner le
pouvoir au peuple. Ils veulent en fait
le pouvoir du roi, ils le veulent dans
leur assemblée pour l'avoir entre eux,
entre parlementaires. Et donc c'est une
sorte de coup d'état coup d'étatnel si
on pourrait dire. Mais pour justifier ce
cette prise du pouvoir des mains du roi
et le ramener dans l'assemblée, l'avir
en toutepuissance, ils vont prétendre
qu'ils font ça pour le peuple. Ils vont
prétendre que le peuple est souverain,
même si en fait il n'est pas souverain.
Et euh et ils vont réussir, ils vont ça
va être ça va être un succès. Et donc
moi quand je voyais le fait que
on appelait père fondateur des
démocraties directes des individus qui
en fait ne se disaient pas démocrate,
qui ne parlaient pas de démocratie sinon
pour le critiquer, je me suis dit il
faut que j'avais comme une énigme. Je
voulais comprendre pourquoi en fait, je
voulais comprendre quand et pourquoi
finalement le mot avait été réhabilité,
si on peut dire ça ou habilité en fait.
Et à partir de quand les élites
politiques ont commencé à dire "Nous
sommes démocrates, nous sommes dans une
démocratie." La France est une
démocratie, les États-Unis sont une
démocratie. Et donc j'ai cherché et avec
le travaux, c'est pas moi, j'ai pas j'ai
pas tout fait tout seul. J'ai lu
d'autres historiens historiennes aux
États-Unis, en France, j'ai comparé les
deux les deux cas. Et en fait, c'est
pour ça que je suis arrivé à la
conclusion que c'est du marketing
politique pour les pauvres, c'est que
euh dans les deux cas, en fait, ça
commence aux États-Unis avec un un type
qui s'appelle Andrew Jackson en 28. Il
se en 1828, donc c'est deux générations
à peu près après l'indépendance, à peu
près deux générations aussi après la
première révolution française. Mais
évidemment la France est toujours plus
compliqué. révolution,
empire, restauration, révolution,
restauration, République et cetera,
Vichi, tout ça. Bon, mais euh
et maintenant Macron mais
euh euh qui n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche, mais euh mais pour revenir à des
choses plus sérieuses, donc c'est ça.
Donc en en 1820 1830 aux États-Unis, il
y a des campagnes électorales.
Les les prés les candidats à la
présidence se présentent comme des
républicains et ils se disent tous pour
la République et tous républicains. Et
Andrew Jackson perd une première fois,
il réfléchit, il réunit ses amis et
cetera. Il se dit "Comment on peut y
aller pour la deuxième fois ? Je veux me
représenter, je veux l'avoir. Et et
ensemble, ils se disent en fait
présente-toi comme démocrate.
D'après si tu commences à à parler à
parler comme un démocrate, que tu dis
que tu es démocrate, que tu défends la
démocratie, que tu es que tu es contre
l'aristocratie financière et contre
l'aristocratie de Washington, donc
l'aristocratie politique et
l'aristocratie financière des des des
protocapitalistes, des manufactures, des
ports et cetera. euh tu vas comme ça
t'adresser directement au peuple et le
peuple va penser que tu prends sa
défense. Et donc Andrejw Jackson a
construit sa campagne en se présentant,
c'est le premier candidat aux États-Unis
en fait qui vraiment se présente comme
défenseur de la démocratie et démocrate.
Il s'adresse principalement aux petits
fermiers indépendants du MOT américain
qui ont une sensibilité plutôt
égalitaire.
pas par rapport aux autochtones, aux
Amérindiens, mais mais par rapport entre
eux, ils sont ils aiment pas tellement
le gouvernement le gouvernement fédéral
de Washington, ils sont pas soumis aux
banques directement ou s'ils sont soumis
aux banques, ça les énerve parce qu'ils
sont endettés. et les travailleurs
manuels de la côtess donc qui
travaillent dans les ports ou dans les
les les début du de l'industrialisation
donc ils sont dans des manufactures euh
donc les travailleurs manuels et donc
c'est à eux que Andrew Jackson se se
s'adresse et il va gagner son il va
gagner son paris, il va gagner
l'élection et c'est tellement efficace
que en 10 ans aux États-Unis tous les
candidats commencent à se dire pour la
démocratie et en fait il commence à
s'obstiner entre eux en disant Toi, tu
es pas un vrai démocrate, c'est moi qui
est un vrai démocrate, tu as volé le nom
et cetera. Et j'avais même pas besoin de
faire d'analyse surplombante sur les
textes de l'époque parce que les
journaux de l'époque, les textes, les
discours des policiers de l'époque et
même des manuels de campagne électorale
de l'époque disaient
"Aucun parti ne peut gagner aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis s'il ne se présente pas
comme démocrate et s'il ne prétend pas
qu'il défend la démocratie." parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on gagne des votes,
c'est comme ça qu'on s'adresse au peuple
et euh et euh et tout ça alors que
Andrew Jackson, c'est le plus important
probablement en terme politique. Euh
alors que une fois qu'il gagne, il ne il
ne transforme en rien le système. Le
système reste exactement le même. Il n'y
a pas plus de possibilité de
participation pour le peuple. Il y a pas
de référendum d'initiative populaire
pour prendre un terme euh à la mode
aujourd'hui.
Euh oui, oui, j'imagine bien. Euh il n'a
pas aboli le Congrès. Évidemment, il n'a
pas aboli la le poste de président
évidemment. Euh et donc c'est vraiment
un changement de nom sans qu'il y ait de
changement institutionnel,
organisationnel qui a plus de
participation pour pour le peuple. En
fait, dans le cas des États-Unis, il y a
même pas à ce moment-là vraiment un
élargissement du suffrage. Et juste pour
terminer et euh mais je vais le faire
beaucoup plus vite et dans
votre temps.
Et dans le cas de dans le cas de la
France, ça arrive quelques années après
parce que l'histoire de la France est
escalée avec la la monarchie. Euh il y a
une particularité en France, c'est que
sous sous les la monarchie restaurée, à
quelques occasions, l'utilisation même
du mot République est considéré comme
dangereux et sédicieux, peut être
interdit ou condamné. Et donc des
républicains même modérés conservateurs
sous la mon sous la monarchie restaurée
vont commencer à se dire démocrate parce
qu'ils cherchent un mot de remplacement.
Dans les années 1830, il y a un début de
mouvement socialiste ouvrier, c'est pas
très clair, c'est en recherche
d'appellation. Et pour se distinguer des
républicains, évidemment tout ce mondel
est antimonarchiste, ils vont aussi se
dire pour une une République
démocratique et sociale. Donc là aussi,
c'est une utilisation du terme pour se
distinguer.
Et puis en France, il y a la fameuse
révolution de 1848 qui restaure la
République à l'époque du printemps des
peuples. Et là 1848, vous avez en fait
bon il va y avoir des élections, la
Merde va prendre le pouvoir et cetera,
mais vous avez quelqu'un comme Auguste
Blanquy qui est un socialiste
révolutionnaire qui est évidemment en
prison comme toujours qui de la prison
dit Auguste Blanquy dit il il empoie un
terme très précis, il dit le mot
démocratie est devenu un mot caoutchou,
c'est-à-dire tellement élastique parce
que dit-il et là je le cite de mémoire
euh aujourd'hui en France on a des
monarchistes démocrates, on a des
socialistes démocrates, on a des
républicains démocrates.
Et Guiso qui est pourtant un politicien
beaucoup plus conservateur que Blanky
fait le même constat. Il dit "Tout le
monde est devenu démocrate aujourd'hui
en France." Évidemment la France c'est
un peu différent de l'exemple que je
donne tout à l'heure parce qu'en fait il
y avait une monarchie où on a réinstauré
la République. Il y a un suffrage dit
universel même si c'est juste les hommes
adultes qui peuvent voter mais mais et
les et non on abolit l'esclavage là en
48 pour la deuxème fois en France.
D'ailleurs là, vous êtes, je pense, le
seul pays qui a abolissé l'esclavage
deux fois, mais euh parce que Napoléon
l'avait rétabli, mais euh
mais euh mais c'est comme aux
États-Unis, c'est-à-dire que ce ce
régime qu'on appelle qu'on que les
fondateurs avaient appelé République et
n'avaient surtout pas voulu appeler
démocratie, maintenant, pour des raisons
électorales, on l'appelle démocratie.
Même si en fait, en terme de
participation concrète du peuple, il y a
rien qui a changé. C'est toujours ce que
j'appelle une aristocratie élue qui
gouverne avec en France et aux
États-Unis en fait un monarque élu, le
président parce qu'on pourrait imaginer
une révolution antimonarchique qui ne
remplace pas le monarque par un
président. On pourrait imaginer un
système où il y a il y a pas de
président mais mais les les régimes
républicains ont coupé la tête du roi
mais ont donné le trône au président. Il
y a pas de couronne mais il garde le
trône, c'est quand même bien. Euh et il
y a ces ces élus qui sont en fait les
les descendants, pas pas héréditaires,
mais les descendants des grands du
Seigneur, des grands du royaume que au
Moyen-Âge les rois convoquaient dans les
premiers premiers parlements parce que
les parlements c'est des inventions
médiévales et et donc on a maintenant
une aristocratie élue avec une monarchie
élue qui s'appelle démocratie. Mais ce
mot démocratie, ce n'est que de la
poudre aux yeux. C'est du marketing
politique. C'est du marketing électoral.
C'est on est il y avait pas le terme à
l'époque, mais c'est exactement ça.
C'est magnifique comme propagande, non ?
C'est passé euh
c'est un grand succès. C'est un succès
extraordinaire. Et donc du coup, c'est
aussi un une sorte de kidnapping euh au
niveau de de concept que le peuple peut
utiliser pour nommer son son propre
projet, disons d'émancipation. Et ça
rend les choses très confuses euh parce
que aujourd'hui on a par exemple, moi je
l'ai déjà fait en sciences politiques et
c'est comme ça que j'ai été formé et moi
j'ai formé des classes comme ça en
disant en répandant ce mythe
complètement faux que la démocratie est
créée à Athène, qu'elle tombe en
dormance pendant comme 2000 sais pas
trop pourquoi et qu'à un moment donné à
Boston si on est américain, à Paris si
on est français, à Ottawa si on est
canadien, j'imagine à Berlin si on est
allemand, là on a réinventé la
démocratie.
Mais
ça ne peut pas être la démocratie
d'Athène parce que aujourd'hui on a des
grandes nations, des grands pays et
cetera. Donc notre démocratie, elle est
représentative ou électorale.
Mais mais c'est une illusion en fait. On
se joue des mots et en se jouant des
mots, on joue avec notre esprit parce
qu'en fait on a deux régimes totalement
différents qui ne devraient pas porter
le même nom. La démocratie Athène, c'est
un endroit où il n'y a pas de
représentant, pas d'élection de cette
forme-là, pas de président, pas
d'Assemblée nationale, euh même pas de
juge et d'avocats en fait. Euh et c'est
vra c'est le peuple. Le peuple c'est ce
sont des hommes grecs évidemment mais
euh qui euh qui gouvernent et il n'y a
aucun lien entre Athène et Paris ou
Boston. En fait, c'est un contreemodèle
Athène et entre les deux, il y a le
Moyen-Âge qu'on oublie tout le temps en
sciences politiques. En tout cas, quand
on enseigne, on oublie tout le temps de
parler du Moyen-Âge. Mais c'est là qu'on
a que les rois ont créé les les premiers
parlements pour pour avoir de l'aide,
pour lever des taxes et des impôts sans
aucune prétention démocratique. Et ces
ces parlements se sont transformés au
fil des générations et sont devenus
l'Assemblée nationale, le Congrès aux
États-Unis et cetera. Et euh c'est pour
ça qu'on a une une aristocratie élective
avec un monarque un monarque élu. Mais
ça a rien à voir avec Athène.
Alors cette monarchie élective que vous
nous décrivez euh elle est bien
enracinée. Euh
elle va très bien. Elle va très bien.
Oui.
Elle va bien hein.
Oui oui oui. Le
je suis pas inquiet pour eux.
Ouis. Il commence à trembler un peu là.
Ils en ont vu d'autres.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais en France on on est
on est très ingénieux. On a inventé le
Freedom Razor. Vous connaissez le
Freedom Rasor ? La guillotine, c'est bon
ça. Mais il y a pas quelqu'un qui s'est
fait condamner là pour être arrivé avec
une guillotine en carton ou je sais pas
quoi là dans les manifestations des
gilets jaunes. Il faut pas déconner, il
faut il faut pas qu'on puisse se
réapproprier les symboles. Non
quand même surtout pas ceux-là.
Ouais ouais. Euh on se fait euh dépossé
de de notre mot. Il y a il y a une prise
de contrôle de la dialectique, de la
rhthorique.
Euh le système éducatif propage,
conforte, cimente, ancre.
Absolument.
Et on fait quoi ? On fait quoi ? On
s'attaque au prof ? On s'attaque à la
langue,
surtout pas au prof
Non, ils sont pas étout pas des sciences
politiques à l'université. En tout cas,
les sciences politiques par exemple,
nous on a on a un truc qui s'appelle
sciences pot à Paris.
Oui. Oui. Ben, c'est
est-ce que c'est un repère ?
C'est pas la même chose que nous. Nous,
on n'est pas des on est pas on n pas de
grandes écoles comme ça au Québec. Donc
SciencePau, moi j'enseigne en Science P.
Bon, je suis prof d'université, c'est je
suis privilégié et tout. Je suis pas en
train de de me plaindre mais c'est pas
le c'est pas exactement la même la même
structuration. Il y a pas il y a moins
d'accès aussi directement vers le le
pouvoir ou l'État ou les les haut
fonctionnaires. Euh mais l'école c'est
très important parce que premièrement le
mythe ce que je viens de présenter le
mythe que nous venons d'Athène et que
nous sommes une une forme moderne de du
régime athénien, ça nous enseigne à
l'école. Euh et on pourrait revenir
là-dessus d'ailleurs parce qu'en plus
euh moi qui viens d'Amérique du Nord, on
sait que les communautés autochtones euh
vivait de façon très démocratique, à la
limite même plus démocratique qu'à
Athène, plus participative, plus
inclusive et cetera et qu'en Afrique ou
ailleurs, il y avait plein d'exemples en
fait de communautés qui se gouvernaient,
on appellerait ça l'autogestion
aujourd'hui ou quelque chose comme ça,
avec des assemblées délibératives, avec
des chefs qui sont pas vraiment des
chefs, qui sont plutô des sortes
d'animateurs culturels médiateurs en
situation de conflit Mais en fait, c'est
pas Athen qui a inventé la démocratie.
L'humanité
a vu des de la démocratie émerger tout
le temps.
La coopération a fait générer
Oui. Oui. Ben puis en aussi c'est que il
y a Athène il y a il y a de la propriété
privée mais dans les communautés par
exemple MoOC ou Inou de la c'est pas
toutes les communautés autochtones qui
vivaient de façon non hiérarchique et
tout mais il y en avait plusieurs qui
vivaient de façon non hiérarchique il y
avait pas de propriété privée. qui
vivait en commun. Et donc quand on vit
en commun, la meilleure chose à faire,
c'est de se réunir et de discuter
ensemble pour prendre nos décisions
ensemble et et du temps
et ils avaient beaucoup de temps.
Ce qui nous manque maintenant, c'est le
temps. Donc on se fait dépossé.
C'est un très bon point. C'est un très
bon point. Il y a des exemples de de
colons qui donnent ou vendent ou
échangent des haches en métal avec des
autochtones dans les Amériques en disant
ils vont pouvoir couper beaucoup plus de
bois, ils vont être plus efficaces.
Alors que les autochtones ce qu'ils font
avec les haches en métal, ben ils
coupent le bois qu'ils ont besoin
beaucoup plus vite puis après ça ils se
reposent parce que ils ont pas besoin
d'en couper plus. Et donc le rapport au
temp évidemment c'est c'est primordial
dans la la pensée de dès qu'on pense à
la démocratie, il faut il faut penser
autant et si on pense au temps, il y a
la question du travail. Est-ce qu'on est
obligé de travailler pour vivre ?
Comment on travaille ? Est-ce qu'on
travaille ensemble ? Est-ce qu'on
travaille pour quelqu'un ? Est-ce qu'on
travaille gratuitement ? Est-ce qu'on
est payé et cetera et cetera ? Est-ce
qu'il faut accumuler pour pour vivre et
cetera ? Tout ça évidemment c'est c'est
très important. On parle jamais de ça
quand on parle de démocratie et on nous
parle pas de ça à l'école et l'État nous
parle pas de ça. Mais je veux revenir à
l'école. Un des arguments qu'on entend
souvent pour expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas avoir de
démocratie directe mais il faut
absolument de la représentation c'est
qu'on nous dit oui mais quand même
Francis là le Canada là c'est immense là
ça fait 4000 km de distance on est 35000
ou 37000 millions d'habitants. On peut
pas être tous ensemble dans un stade
prendre nos décisions ensemble. Donc on
n pas le choix. C'est toujours cette
idée qu'on a pas le choix, une sorte de
fatalité civilisationnelle, ce qui est
très bizarre parce qu'en fait dans la
modernité, il y a plein d'exemples de
gens qui se réunissent ensemble pour
discuter et tout, mais on entend tout le
temps ça. Or, un endroit où on aurait
vraiment le temps et la place, où il y a
pas ce problème de la taille du
territoire et de la taille du groupe,
c'est dans les écoles primaires et
secondaires, dans les classes. classes,
vous avez sans doute été à l'école euh
pendant 8 mois ou 7 mois, on est les 30
ou 25 ou 35 ensemble dans la même
classe. On est dans le même espace, on
se connaît. Mais plutôt que de nous
faire, disons j'imagine tous les
vendredis après-midi, à la fin du mois,
tenir une réunion ensemble pour parler
de ce qu'on a envie de faire ou régler
des problèmes à l'école. Non, à l'école,
ils nous font élire des conseils
d'élèves. On nous apprend, on nous
endoctrine dès l'école à voter. Et moi,
j'ai étudié les documents
d'accompagnement pour organiser des
élections dans des écoles primaires et
secondaires au Québec. C'est organisé en
coopération avec le ministère de
l'éducation et le directeur général des
élections. Donc l'agence
paragouvernementale qui encadre les
élections pour adultes et ils expliquent
les élections d'élèves, c'est pour
former la soueté, c'est pour former les
enfants à apprendre à voter. Parce que
vous savez que voter c'est très
compliqué hein. Il faut il faut mettre
un papier dans une urne. Donc si on nous
apprend pas ça, quand on est jeune, on
est foutu, on y arrivera jamais, on va
mettre à côté ou je sais pas ce qu'on va
faire. Et donc quand on est adulte, je
pense que c'est la même chose en France.
En plus, on met en l'élection exactement
dans le même espace à dans une école. Je
sais pas si vous votez dans des écoles
mais nous en tout cas les gens qui vont
voter, ils vont voter dans les écoles.
Donc on revient exactement dans le même
gymnase où quand on était petit, on
votait et on refait le même geste. Alors
qu'à l'école, si on si on se préoccupait
vraiment d'une sorte de formation
citoyenne, politique d'engagement
citoyen pour nos nos enfants et que on
était vraiment convaincu que le problème
c'est la taille de la population de la
taille géographique de nos nations et de
nos pays, mais on pourrait se dire
chouette là on a une occasion pendant 5
6 7 ans, les enfants, ils sont un petit
groupe dans un espace et on va leur
faire apprendre la politique autrement.
Ils vont pouvoir délibérer ensemble. Ils
auront pas de chef, pas de représentant,
ils vont pas voter et s'ils ont envie
d'écrire une pétition, ils écriront une
pétition. S'ils ont envie de Mais non,
on les a on leur apprend tout de suite à
voter comme si c'était il comme ici, il
pouvait pas faire autre chose que ça. Et
ça, on dit c'est ça la formation
l'estrieté, même si vous et moi on sait
très bien qu'en fait ce fameux conseil
d'élèves, il sert strictement à rien.
C'est complètement bidon. au mieux, il
discute de la sortie d'hiver euh avec
euh à la montagne ou des choses comme
ça, mais en fait il il sert à rien.
Qui passe le balai ?
Ah, même pas parce que ça les balis
c'est des travailleurs euh probblement
précaires qui qui qui sont le soir à
passer le balet, effacer le tableau des
fois. Les
Moi, j'avais ça comme moi j'étais dans
mon conseil d'élèves, j'avais la
responsabilité, c'était moi qui a façais
le tableau noir. J'étais très très fier.
C'est vrai.
Ah ben là,
bon, c'est de l'éducation civique ou
c'est de l'endoctrinement à ce niveau ?
Ben c'est de l'endoctrinement.
C'est de l'endoctrinement. les je veux
dire les les libéraux républicains
quand il voi quand il voyaient ça se
fait plus tellement mais quand il voyait
par exemple les camp de jeunesse
communiste avec les enfants communistes
qui chantaient des chants
révolutionnaires à 7 8 ans, il disaient
"Mais c'est scandaleux, les communistes
en doctrine les enfants, c'est
épouvantable. Nous on n'oserait jamais
faire un truc comme ça. Nous on les
éveille à la pensée critique et cetera."
Mais non, nous on leur apprend à voter.
On les apprend c'est le conformisme
qu'on leur apprend. C'est la soumission.
C'est
ben en fait c'est ce qui vient avec,
c'est que le le pouvoir politique, il
passe par le vote.
On leur on on leur apprend pas autre
chose. Le pouvoir politique passe par le
vote et dans les écoles, c'est plus
important de faire voter que de que de
faire élire. C'est-à-dire ce que je veux
dire, c'est on porte plus d'attention à
faire voter la masse que à ceux qui vont
vraiment être élus sur le le conseil
parce que le conseil ça rien. Donc on on
on essaie de convaincre les enfants que
l'action politique, elle passe, elle est
elle est elle est canalisée par le vote.
aux États-Unis, au Canada, je peut-être
vous avez la même chose en France, on a
même les journées des élections des aux
États-Unis des agences
des agences qui organisent des des
fausses élections, des simulations
d'élections dans les écoles. Donc, vous
pouvez voter pour Hillary Clinton ou
Trump. Euh et nous maintenant au Québec
et au Canada, on a des dans les bureaux
de électoraux, les parents peuvent venir
avec leurs enfants et il y a un un une
pour les enfants. Donc euh comme avant,
on allait à la messe avec nos parents,
maintenant on va aux élections avec nos
parents et ils le disent ouvertement,
ils le disent comme ça, on forme les
futurs électeurs. Ah,
c'est beau, c'est magnifique,
c'est émouvant,
c'est Ouais. Le bon la démocratie, on a
vu que c'était une tarte à la crème.
Oui.
Euh est-ce qu'on peut parler de la
souveraineté liée à la guerre ?
À la guerre à Athè ou euh maintenant ?
Bon
maintenant ou comme vous voulez. La
question est ouverte.
À Athène, c'était très important. À
Athène à Athène la citoyenneté liée avec
euh avec avec la capacité à faire la
guerre. La capacité en principe bien des
femmes ont la capacité à faire la guerre
et bien des hommes ont pas de capacité à
faire la guerre. Mais on présuppose que
c'est les hommes qui ont la capacité à
faire la guerre et donc à atteine les
l'argument, c'est toujours une excuse
évidemment, mais l'argument des hommes
pour que ça soit eux qui a le pouvoir,
c'est que c'est que c'est eux qui
faisaient la guerre. Cela dit, je suis
cyénique, mais en même temps, cela dit,
leur méthode de prendre des décisions
par rapport à la guerre et de partir en
guerre était quand même d'un point de
vue éthique et politique quand même plus
intéressant que dans nos sociétés
modernes. Parce que dans nos sociétés
modernes, comme vous le savez, ceux qui
décident de faire la guerre vont jamais
faire la guerre. Ils
leurs enfants d'ailleurs,
je rarement leurs enfants et ils
attendent que la guerre soit bien
avancée et cetera. Et là, il se ils
s'organise une une opération de photos
de photos médiatiques. Et donc là, ils
arrivent en hélicoptère et là, ils sont
pris en photo avec des enfants afghans,
avec ils serrent des mains et cetera.
Puis après ça, évidemment avec des
militaires. George W. Bush, le président
États-Unis, était même arrivé avec une
dinde en plastique pour Thanksgiving.
Euh euh bref, ils arrivent avec des
cadeaux, tout ça, tout ça, c'est très
émouvant. Puis après ça, ils repartent
avec des pinup, de temps en temps, ils
viennent
si possible. Ça peut aussi ça peut aussi
être sympa. Euh et donc euh
et donc nous on a un système un système
absurde où les gens qui déclarent la
guerre euh euh ne la font pas euh ne
prennent en fait aucun risque et la euh
ne prennent ne prennent ne prennent
aucun risque et comme vous avez dit
généralement leurs enfants et leurs
proches, ils ont des des différentes
manières de leur de les exter de de des
opérations de des opérations de combat.
Et donc je reviens à mes citoyens
athéniens
euh si on peut si on peut dire euh sans
vouloir faire l'apologie de la guerre et
de la conquête. Euh eux dans tous les
cas l'assemblée athénienne quand elle
décidait de faire la guerre et elle a
décidé très souvent de faire la guerre
d'ailleurs, euh ben c'était eux qui
partaient en guerre et c'était eux qui
prenaient les risques mais évidemment
c'était eux qui avaient aussi les
avantages puisqu'ils disaient parce que
leur guerre c'était aussi des guerres de
pillage de conquête. Et euh
on dit que à Athène, même si les femmes
dans les faits n'avaient pas le la
citoyenneté politique,
en s'inspirant de en analysant des des
pièces de théâtre d'Aristophane, par
exemple, on voit que probablement les
femmes athéniennes à un certain moment
euh ont protesté contre contre cette
propension de leurs hommes à aller en
guerre parce qu'elles en subissaient
quand même des conséquences et euh et
elles elles ont elles ont probablement
manifesté, elles ont probement même
saboter des statuts des statutes sacrés
pour protester pour protester contre
tout ça. Et la la l'idée de la
souveraineté et de la guerre, elle est
revenu euh avec la Révolution française
par exemple chez les Républicains.
C'était un des arguments euh
essentialistes évidemment par rapport
aux hommes et aux femmes pour dire aux
femmes chez les républicains, on vous
enlève les armes. La souveraineté, la
politique, c'est une affaire d'homme.
Même si au début de la Révolution
française, les femmes sont dans les
armées des deux côtés. D'ailleurs, il
peut avoir des des femmes vendéennes ou
royalistes. Là, c'est pas c'est pas
parce qu'on est femmes qu'on est
révolutionnaire ou républicaine,
évidemment. Euh mais euh mais
régulièrement quand il y a des quand il
y a des guerres, quand les affrontements
armés, les hommes tendantiellement vont
dire vont associer guerre et guerre et
souveraineté et pouvoir politique avec
évidemment quelques exceptions notables
comme la résistance par exemple
Yougoslave contre contre les nazis ou en
ce moment les Kurdes par exemple.
Oui, les curdes, les femmes sont
énormément représentées dans
C'est ça exactement. Et depuis depuis
très longtemps d'ailleurs, il des unités
militaires de femmes depuis bien avant
les débuts de la guerre là récente là.
Revenons à l'élection de notre petite
clique.
On est au 21e siècle.
Apparemment. Oui.
Euh on a un président qui se déclare
démocrate
en France.
Ouais.
Oui.
Euh républicain.
Il protège la République, il protège la
démocratie. Oui.
Euh mais quand je vous écoute, j'ai
l'impression en fait que c'est du gros
pipo.
Oui. Oui. Ben je pense que on est
plusieurs à voir ça. Je pense pas. Je
suis certain que je suis pas tout seul.
Euh
on fait comment euh pour reprendre les
les vraies racines ? On fait comment
pour que le peuple le peuple se
réapproprie son du ? Oui. Alors,
moi, je suis euh peut-être plus euh j'ai
peut-être plus de talent, je sais pas si
à vous de juger, mais j'ai peut-être
plus de talent pour critiquer ou
analyser dans une perspective critique
que pour vraiment offrir des solutions
stratégiques euh très efficaces. Je suis
plutôt euh pessimiste par rapport à tout
ça, mais c'est sûr que moi mon espoir ou
en tout cas mon engagement ou là où je
regarde, mon empathie ou ma solidarité,
disons, elle va pas du tout, vous aurez
compris, j'imagine, du côté électoral.
Donc l'idée c'est pas de de créer un x
parti d'opposition qui ferait les choses
différemment parce que finalement ils
font jamais les choses si différemment
que ça. Euh et moi j'ai vraiment
beaucoup d'espoir, un espoir modéré mais
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir dans les
mouvements sociaux, les mouvements
sociaux autonomes et euh et pour moi
c'est c'est là qu'il y a des choses
vraiment intéressantes en terme
politique dans le vrai sens du mot
démocratie aussi. C'est là qu'il y a des
choses, c'est là qu'il y a des choses
qui se passent. Quand les gens vraiment
se rencontrent, discutent, échangent,
prennent des décisions ensemble et et
agissent ensemble, moi, on est dans
quelque chose qui ressemble à de la
démocratie. Alors, on peut vous objecter
que les les petits groupes de IP avec
des dreadlocks qui se mettent dans des
odes pour défendre des triton
Oui.
euh ils peuvent pas quand même pas gérer
un état, ils peuvent pas gérer une force
nucléaire, ils peuvent pas gérer un
système économique. On leur objecte
souvent que les turbulents ça crée de
l'instabilité dans la démocratie, ça
crée de l'instabilité politique,
ils deviennent dangereux. Euh euh
qu'est-ce que vous avez à répondre à aux
gens qui vous objectent ça ? Cette
incapacité du peuple à s'autogouverner.
Oui,
ils ont besoin de chef quand même, faut
pas déconner.
Donc euh
l'avocat du diable.
Oui oui oui.
Vous êtes bien payé par le diable. Les
avocats généralement sont bien payés.
Non, je je fais des blagues blagu dire.
On est payé que par notre communauté.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Donc c'est il y a
plusieurs diables. Euh ouais, ils sont
nombreux.
Ils sont nombreux. Ils sont nombreux.
C'est des diabletins.
Euh des démons là carrément. Oui, mais
on est en train de voir leurs questions
arriver là.
Mais euh oui, c'est un argument qu'on
qu'on entend. On en fait, je pensais
même que vous alliez euh lancer une
question plus perfaide encore sur la
question de la nature humaine. Est-ce
que les êtres humains sont vraiment
faits pour vivre de façon égalitaire et
collaborative et tout ?
J'y allais, j'y venais. Est-ce qu'il y a
pas une caste ? Parce que tel qu'on nous
le décrit, il y a l'élite.
Oui.
Et et les moutons ? Oui.
Et et pour qu'un mouton euh se fasse
bien tondre, vous savez, il faut pas
qu'il bouge.
Non, il faut pas qu'il bouge. Et après
être tondu, il peut même être manger.
Et euh
donc
je commence par la nature humaine.
Faites faites-vous plaisir.
Et après euh après sur sur Lazade et les
Dreadslock, vous comprendrez que
j'ai une autre perception des des enjeux
capillaires, mais ça c'est un autre
problème. Euh
les la appelons ça la démocratie directe
ou l'anarchie c'est c'est assez proche
mais l'anarchie dans le sens positif là
l'anarchie
vraie anarchie
dans le sens de l'autogestion don on vit
ensemble on a pas de on a pas de on n
pas de gouvernement on n pas de chef et
cetera puis ça fonctionne. On on oppose
souvent à ces à ces projets
une on évoque une nature humaine qui
nous mènerait toujours à la compétition,
à la concurrence et à une structuration
hiérarchique des rapports. Même si on
est bien intentionné, on le sait dans
n'importe quelle communauté, il y a
toujours un chef qui émerge, quelqu'un
qui a plus d'influence et cetera. Et
souvent euh quand on nous dit ça, on va
nous rapporter euh telle observation de
30 chimpanzés où on voit bien qu'il y a
un mal alpha et cetera. Et donc là, avec
ça, on vient de on vient d'éviter de
réfléchir à des centaines de milliers
d'années de d'histoires humaines, des
des centaines des milliers d'exemples de
communautés humaines qui ont vécu comme
ceci ou comme cela. et toute la
diversité de la vie humaine et de la
façon de s'organiser en famille, en
clan, en tribus, en communauté, en cité,
en nation et cetera. Il y a il y a il y
a tellement de manières de s'organiser
qui a été expérimenté par les humains
que de toujours amener ça à la nature
humaine nous impose ceci ou cela ou
c'est c'est
ça sera nécessairement comme cela ou les
chimpansés on voit ça donc les humains
sont comme ça pour moi c'est vraiment
une une réduction de notre imaginaire
politique de nos capacités de nos
potentiels humains politiques que de
penser que de penser comme ça euh
je vais me permettre de citer ça fait un
peu professeur Elle mais je me permets
de citer des auteurs anarchistes qui ont
répondu à cette question parce que
souvent les anarchistes ont dit ils sont
trop naïfs. Euh Pierre
euh non, ils sont souvent pas très naïfs
du tout. Et Pierre en fait, je vais
commencer en disant les groupes
militants que moi je connais, les
groupes anarchistes que moi je connais
dans le mouvement intermondaliste
anticapitaliste,
la mobilisation contre la brutalité
policière et d'autres féministes radical
aussi en fait ce sont des gens c'est les
gens les plus obsédés par les les
rapports de pouvoir informel que je
connaisse en fait. J'ai l'impression que
dans leur rêve, ils essaient de voir
quel personnage dans leur rêve a plus
d'influence que l'autre pour essayer
d'égaliser tout ça. Ils sont ils ne
pensent qu'à ça et ils ont mis en place
plein de rituels, de procédures, de
techniques pour essayer de réduire les
pouvoirs informels entre les gens. Parce
que évidemment les anarchistes, ils sont
tout à fait conscients que euh quand on
arrive dans un groupe anarchiste, don on
forme un groupe anarchiste, on est une
dizaine de personnes. Euh euh toi, tu as
plus de connaissances en informatique,
toi tu as une voiture, toi tu as de
l'argent, toi tu es un homme, tu es plus
confiant, tu parles plus, toi tu parles
moins, toi tu ceci cela. Il ils le
savent qu'il y a des il y a des pouvoirs
informels et que tout le monde est pas
égal dans la réalité, pareil et cetera.
Euh mais il mettent en place des façons
de euh de réduire ces euh ses
inégalités, de réduire ces jeux
d'influence. Ça serait jamais parfait.
Moi, je vous connais pas. Mais moi, en
tout cas et mes amis, je sais qu'on
n'est pas parfait. Et si on n'est pas
parfait en tant qu'être humain, on aura
jamais un système politique parfait. Ça
existe pas les systèmes politiques
parfaits.
On est imparfait pour plein de raisons,
pas juste moralement ou en terme de
qualité. On est imperfait au niveau
cognitif. Moi, je peux avoir une bonne
idée, une bonne tactique, une bonne
stratégie, une bonne idée de d'action,
mais en fait je serai jamais réellement
capable de prévoir totalement les effets
de mon action et les autres aussi
agissent et je serais pas capable, mon
l'être humain est pas capable de tout
prévoir en terme d'interaction entre
humain, l'adversaire réagit et cetera.
Donc, on essae des choses, on fait des
choses, des fois ça marche, des fois ça
fonctionne pas, des fois et cetera. Bon
et donc il y a des techniques pour
réduire les le pouvoir informel
qui est toujours là euh qui sera
toujours là. Mais il y a des sociétés où
il y a plus de pouvoirs, plus de
pouvoirs formels et plus de pouvoirs
informel que d'autres. tout n'est pas
pareil et c'est pas la nature humaine
que tout soit toujours pareil et tout
soit toujours identique et tout soit
toujours hiérarchisé de façon verticale.
Et puis cette fameuse question du
pouvoir informel où on dit mais les
groupes qui veulent pratiquer la
démocratie directe et l'anarchie en fait
ils ont ils sont minés par du pouvoir
informel.
Laisse entendre que dans nos
institutions officielles, il y aurait
pas de pouvoir informel.
Et donc vous allez essayer de me faire
croire que par exemple le fils Bush a
été élu président des États-Unis sans
sans sans avantage informel alors qu'il
était le fils de l'autre. C'est je crois
pas ça du tout. Vous allez croire que
Macron il il avait autant de chance que
n'importe quel français qui serait
présenté présenté à la présidence de
devenir président. C'est complètement
absurde. Vous pensez que dans le conseil
des ministres au parlement et cetera, il
y a pas de pouvoir informel. Il y a
juste un pouvoir formel. les pouvoirs
formels, les organisations formelles de
pouvoir très hiérarchiqu de domination,
ils sont
euh ils sont euh très fortement
influencés aussi par du pouvoir euh par
du pouvoir informel. Très important,
beaucoup plus important même en fait que
dans les fameux groupes anarchistes dont
je vous parle dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure, le jeu de l'argent, le jeu de
l'éducation, le jeu des contacts, le jeu
des influences, le jeu des même des
menaces, des des petits marchés entre
amis et cetera. C'est beaucoup plus
important que les que le que la
structure euh que la structure euh
formelle des fois. Et donc euh il faut
faire attention quand on critique les
organisations disons de démoc les
espoirs de démocratie directe et
d'anarchie en disant vous allez vous y
arriverez pas parce qu'il y a toujours
des pouvoirs informels comme si dans les
institutions formelles, il y a pas de
pouvoir informel. C'est absurde. Et là
il y avait une deuxième question dont je
ne me rappelle plus quelle elle était.
Et on va on va la sauter celle-là. Si
non si je vous dis mettre de
l'intelligence artificielle dans tous
ces processus, si mettre la machine pour
réguler, gérer et
on va dire faire une démocratie
par les robots, qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ?
Ah oui, l'autre question c'était est-ce
qu'on est capable de gérer est-ce que
les indistes sont capables de gérer la
France
aussi ?
Et donc sans robot au départ.
Allez
euh
j'y reviens quand même parce que c'est
important. Euh moi je ne suis pas le
porte-parole des adistes et euh je ne
suis pas adiste. Donc les adistes, ils
peuvent avoir leur avis qui est sans
doute pas d'ailleurs il y en a sans
doute pas un seul sur leur capacité ou
non ou leur désir d'ailleurs de de gérer
quelque chose qui s'appelle comme la
France euh
et les centrales nucléaires et tout ça.
Euh
on peut renverser la question, on peut
se dire pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi
est-ce qu'on tient absolument à voir des
grands ensembles ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
tient absolument à voir des grands
ensembles comme les pays modernes qui
sont en fait des excroissances de du
Moyen-Âge, des monarchies, des royaumes
du Moyen-Âge ? En fait, ça vient
directement de là. C'est ces États
modernes avec ces nations modernes avec
ses noms. D'ailleurs, la France, c'est
le royaume de France. La
Grande-Bretagne, c'est le royaume
d'Angleterre. L'Espagne, c'est c'est le
Donc tout ça nous vient du Moyen-Âge. On
les on l'a consolidé, on a créé l'État,
on a on a consolidé les frontières, on a
consolidé le contrôle, on a créé des
États.
Le 20e siècle, c'est le siècle de
l'étatisation de l'humanité. On est de
on a des États qui ont des ministères
pour tout. Il y a même des ministères du
sport. Mais pourquoi l'État s'occupe du
sport ? C'est absurde. On s'en fout du
sport. On s'en fout. et cetera, on peut
vous
santé publique pour améliorer la santé
des gens.
Le nombre de ministères montre l'ampleur
en fait de la prise de de la volonté de
l'État de s'occuper de tout dans la vie
de tout le monde quoi. Et donc la
première chose qu'on peut dire c'est on
peut on peut répliquer à ceux qui
s'inquiètent à savoir si les adistes
seront capables de gérer la France.
Moi, si j'étais eux, je m'inquiéterai
d'autres choses parce que avant avant
que ça arrive, il va avoir d'autres
problèmes. Euh peut-être la la fin de la
civilisation à cause du climat, par
exemple. Mais bon, disons que demain
matin là, on le sait pas mais en fait
les adistes ont un plan puis demain
matin en fait c'est bon là il ils
prennent le contrôle de la France, ils
prennent un peu tout le monde par
surprise. Il fait beau en plus on porte
attention à autre chose. Euh moi je
pense que les addistes ou les
anarchistes ou les démocrates la
démocratie directe, moi je pense que
premièrement elle réorganiserait tout
ça. Euh il y aurait pas ce serait pas à
l'identique mais géré par le peuple. Je
pense que ça serait non seulement géré
autrement, mais ça serait autre chose.
Ça serait peut-être plus la France, ça
serait peut-être plus l'Union
européenne, ça serait peut-être plus
l'Espagne. À la limite, ça serait
peut-être le quelque chose qui qui a une
dimension qui a une dimension humaine,
si je peux dire. Et puis pour les
centrales nucléaires, là
on va pas me faire croire que les États
gèrent bien le nucléaire. Là,
ça c'est ça c'est pas un argument quand
même là. comme les États, ils
construisent du nucléaire et ils se
foutent complètement de ce qui va
arriver dans 100 200 300 ans. Ils
coulent du béton, ils ferment les yeux,
ils se disent : "Je pense que ça va
tenir le temps que nous on espérons
peut-être nos enfants et nos petits
enfants." Mais tout le monde sait que ça
va craquer ce truc-là. Tout le monde
sait que ça tout le monde sait que c'est
foutu. C'est pas On va pas demander aux
adistes de sauver la planète là quand
même. Là, ils ont c'est les adistes,
c'est des adistes là. C'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas des divinités
toutepuissantes. Et c'est les c'est les
États qui nous bluffent en disant que
nous on est capable de gérer la planète.
Ils sont ils gèrent pas la planète de
tous les États. Ils sont en train de
tout détruire. Donc moi, j'essaierai
avec les adistes.
Ils ont l'air déjà plus sympathique.
Et puis en plus, ils font du très bon
pain. Euh euh
pour revenir à nos robots,
les robots, donc ça c'est une très bonne
question et je pense que je n'ai pas de
très bonne réponse parce que je suis un
technosaure ou technopl ou appelez-moi
comme vous voulez. J'ai pas de téléphone
cellulaire. J'essaie de d'utiliser mon
ordinateur. J'ai très peu de
connaissance, j'ai peu étudié ça aussi.
Donc je suis un peu je suis un peu un
imposteur si j'essaie de vous sortir une
théorie ou une réflexion substantielle
sur la le Alors, et je dis pas que c'est
pas important, je dis pas que c'est pas
un sujet extrêmement important même qui
a plein d'implication à la fois
possiblement d'émancipation et de
contrôle mais je suis sûr que vous avez
d'autres invités qui pourront en parler
vraiment beaucoup mieux que moi.
Ouais. Ouais. Donc on va vous renvoyer
sur une question sur vos votre domaine
de compéten
euh
je sélectionne
hop. Désolé pour ce blanc. Alors, les
manœuvres politiques, la soif du
pouvoir, les démagogues.
Oui.
La démagogie, c'est quoi le ce mot-là ?
Pourquoi on on entend beaucoup parler en
ce moment ? Euh, les démagogues, les
populistes, ces choses-là. Oui. Euh
ça revient un peu avec ce que je disais
euh ce que je disais au début. Donc
désolé pour les
désolé de de reculer, mais
les démagogues pour moi, c'est euh
la démagogie pour moi, elle est dans
l'ADN du système parlementaire et du
système électoral. Il y a évidemment des
régimes, il y a évidemment il y a
évidemment d'autres régimes qui
utilisent la démagogie. En fait, je
dirais selon moi, à chaque fois que vous
avez des gens au pouvoir, il va y avoir
une certaine forme de démagogie parce
qu'ils doivent bien dire quelque chose
aux personnes qui le qui le qui le
domine. Euh mais euh la démagogie
implique quelque chose comme pas juste
une justification de dire je suis là, je
suis je vous je vous gouverne parce que
je suis le fils de Dieu ou je suis le
dieu soleil ou je suis le descendant de
machin ou et cetera. Mais euh la démogie
implique aussi euh de bluffer le peuple
par rapport à ses propres intérêts.
C'est de faire croire en fait qu'on est
euh qu'on est euh à son service. On le
flatte dans le sens du poil, on est bien
pour lui, on l'écoute, on prend soin de
lui et cetera. Mais en fait, tout ça,
c'est du bluff, la démagogie parce que
dans la réalité évidemment l'objectif
c'est de d'asseoir et de consolider, de
perpétuer le notre pouvoir sur ce sur ce
peuple. Et en fait le le l'intérêt
premier c'est toujours celui du
gouvernant. Et euh et donc la démagogie,
elle est dans l'ADN du système
électoral. C'est impossible d'avoir un
système électoral où il y a pas de
démagogie parce que vous voulez vous
faire élire. Et pour vous faire élire,
il faut que vous dites vous vous disiez
à l'électorat "Je suis le meilleur. Je
suis le meilleur pour vous."
Ça ira mieux demain voter pour moi.
Exactement. et les autres sont nuls. Euh
et euh et c'est pour moi qu'il faut
voter. Et le système électoral, il c'est
un système les autres systèmes
politiques aussi peuvent peuvent
encourager le mensonge, mais le système
électoral, il encourage le mensonge. Il
est il est conçu comme ça. Et
maintenant, c'est tellement euh pris
pour acquis que vous avez quelque chose
que vous n'aviez pas il y a 100 150 ans.
Vous avez déjà les partis, les partis
politiques sont des machines à
confectionner
du rêve et du mensonge. Et et il y a
même il y a même les équipes de
marketing docteur
ils embauchent ils embauchent des gens
qui sont spécialistes de marketing. Donc
ils vendent ils vendent ils vendent du
produit.
Donc on est vraiment c'est c'est caché.
C'estàd c'est c'est c'est discret ces
compagnies de marketing mais tout le
monde ces questions là c'est pas c'est
pas c'est même pas illégal de toute
façon c'est tout à fait légal et on sait
très bien ce qu'elles font ces
compagnies de marketing elles vont
jusqu'à regarder la couleur de la
cravate la coiffure évidemment les
éléments de langage comme on dit en
anglais le oneel liner la phrase la
phrase choc le slogan la couleur le logo
de la campagne les photos des candidats
et cetera donc là on est dans on est
dans on est dans une régression totale
et on est dans le dans le dans la
version la plus médiocre de de la
démagogie. Après ça, il y a des
personnes qui vont dire le populisme
c'est quelque chose d'un peu différent
parce que le populisme a aussi ce côté
où généralement qu'on définit le
populisme en sciences politiques ou
ailleurs, souvent on va dire mais c'est
aussi le outsiders, c'est-à-dire celui
qui se présente comme quelqu'un qui
vient de l'extérieur du serrail des des
de des politiciens des politiciennes
habituelles. Et celui qui arrive de
l'extérieur pour des raisons que Jingor,
il se présente toujours comme quelqu'un
qui s'est fait lui-même, qui s de
selfman man pour évoquer Trump par
exemple
qui est plus proche du peuple
nécessairement comme Trump, on le voit
très bien, c'est les milliardaires sont
toujours proches du peuple, n'est-ce pas
? euh et puisqu'ils ont un chauffeur et
et
donc là évidemment le populisme est
souvent associé à ça et il y a des il y
a des gens qui qui veulent opposer
populiste de droite à populiste de
gauche. Je pense à une philosophe comme
Chantal Mouf par exemple qui est proche
qui est proche de
partis comme Podemos ou qui était proche
de Chavz au Venezuela qui elle rêve de
chef charismatique
qui incarnerait le renouveau de la
gauche euh et qui est très critique en
fait de la démocratie directe et des des
gros anarchistes et des mouvements
sociaux sans chef. Elle dit tout le
temps, elle elle avait critiqué nuit
debout, elle critiquerait sûrement les
gilets jaunes évidemment, elle a
critiqué les les anarchistes alterons
disait ce le problème avec ces groupes
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de chef et donc
ils n'ont pas de relais politique parce
que pour ell la avoir une une prise sur
le réel politique ça passe toujours par
les lois, ça passe toujours par le
parlement. Il
lié au système,
il faut par il faut il faut il faut
attendre du système les solutions et il
faut surtout pas se prendre en main. Au
mieux, selon cette conception, il faut
avoir des mouvements sociaux qui
moussent en fait d'une certaine manière
la popularité du parti qui est le parti
sauveur.
Est-ce que vous avez lu propaganda ?
Ça fait quelques temps. Ouais. de Bernie
Bernis.
Édouard Berne ?
Ouais.
Alors question d'internet, qu'avez-vous
à dire sur Edward Bernais qui a théorisé
le marketing politique ?
Mais c'est une bonne question. J'aurais
pas de je ne serais c'est une une
question quiz à laquelle je ne serais
pas capable de répondre précément ou de
dire quelque chose de j'ai j'ai lu son
livre il y a quelques années. Je
m'inscris dans une logique de critique
du marketing politique évidemment mais
je serais pas capable de de développer
spécifiquement sur cet hauteur.
Si je vous dis podemos la Liga 5
étoiles.
Oui.
Démagogue populiste.
Oui. Et et là
dit la République en marche
c'est pas la même. C'est pas la même,
c'est pas la même tendance, c'est pas
exactement la même chose. Mais la
République en marche quand ils ont
commencé, moi je
je suis ce qui se passe en France. Je
suis pas spécialiste politique
française, donc peut-être la personne
qui m'a posé la question connaît mieux
connaît mieux que ça que moi. Mais ce
que j'ai ce qui me semble que Macron a
essayé de faire à ce moment-là qui il me
semble qu'il a d'ailleurs plutôt réussi,
c'est qu'il il a il a joué ce cette
espèce de chef charismatique pour les
personnes qui le trouvent charismatique.
Euh qui se dit "Ben moi, je vais faire
table race des anciens partis, je vais
proposer quelque chose de neuf qui vient
de la base. ce queiza prétenda ce que
Podemos a prétendu après le mouvement
des indignés en 2000 en 2011 et le
mouvement des places. Ces mouvements
disent euh nous venons du vrai peuple.
Donc euh Macron évidemment c'est un peu
c'est un peu particulier mais mais son
mouvement en masse au début c'était des
gens qui allaient euh cogner aux portes,
rencontrer des gens et cetera qui
étaient des sortes de bénévoles
volontaires et enthousiastes pour cette
candidature et qui a réussi à torpiller
en fait euh son ancien parti socialiste
et de à bluffer les autres les autres
partis. Mais ces parties quand on les
regarde plus attentivement, évidemment
Macron c'est évidemment encore pire que
les autres j'imagine. Mais la République
en marche. Mais quand on regarde Podemos
en Espagne pour ce que j'en sais, ils
ont encore une une structure qui à
l'intérieur du parti a l'air plus
démocratique. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
espaces de discussion, des espaces de
proposition, des espaces de délibération
pour les comités locaux et cetera. Mais
en fait, quand on regarde attentivement,
il y a clairement une il y a clairement
une hiérarchie, il y a clairement une
clé au sommet. Et ce qu'ils veulent
comme tout politicien qui est dans le
système électoral, ils veulent ils
veulent ils veulent avoir des sièges.
Ils veulent ils veulent être élus, avoir
des sièges et gouverner.
Si je vous dis la rationalité du
capitalisme, ça a créé des avions, ça a
créé ça envoyer le monde dans l'homme
sur la lune, c'est c'est fonctionnel
quand même.
Ah
le capitalisme qui la la main du
capitalisme, les marchés qui guident
notre société, c'est
Mais ça c'est ça c'est tout à fait
fonctionnel. Le système parlementaire
que je critique, il est fonctionnel.
Le régime soviétique est fonctionnel, la
monarchie est fonctionnelle, le système
feudal est fonctionnel, les systèmes ils
sont les systèmes, ils sont
fonctionnels. Des fois, ils durent 100
ans, 200 ans, 70 ans, 500 ans.
les les systèmes les inuites dans le
grand nord qu'on a sédentarisé de que le
gouvernement canadien a sédentariser de
force en abattant leurs chiens sous
prétexte de préoccupation sanitaire dans
les années 50 mais en fait parce qu'on
avait besoin en fait en pleine guerre
froide de surveiller les missiles
soviétiques qui viendraient vers les
États-Unis parce que quand on regarde
une carte du monde à plat on pense que
ça allait être est-ouest mais en fait la
ligne la plus courte pour se détruire
mutuellement ça passait par la calotte
polaire et donc par le Canada. Et donc
on essaie d'entariser les inuites mais
les inuites ils ont vécu comme ça
pendant des milliers d'années. Donc tous
les systèmes politiques ou économiques
sont fonctionnel selon leur propre
principes et des fois même d'ailleurs
pas selon leur principes. Ils sont
souvent ils ont souvent des principes
contradictoires mais ils fonctionnent.
La question après ça c'est qui en
profite ou en profite pas ? Qui se sent
spolier ou pas ? Qui est en colère ou
pas ? Qui qui sont les forces concesses
qui peuvent améliorer ou faire bouger
les choses ? C'est ça la question. Donc
le capitalisme entre guillemets, il
fonctionne même si accessoirement il va
peut-être détruire la planète et
l'humanité mais pour l'instant il
fonctionne. Moi, je suis venu, je suis
venu à Paris avec mon empreunte
écologique, je suis pris un avion,
l'avion était à l'heure.
Bon,
la prochaine fois, il faudra venir en
kayak. Oui, mais je sais pas nager,
c'est un peu ça ça m'angoisse.
Euh si je vous dis le tirage au sort,
oui,
euh quand on est égau,
ça marche.
Alors, le tirage au sort, ça dépend
pourquoi, ça dépend comment, mais le
tirage au sort, c'est une des bon, il y
a le référendum d'initiative populaire,
tirage au sort, ça c'est des choses qui
sont souvent discutées présentement.
On y va. Oui. Bon euh donc ça c'est
souvent présenté comme des solutions.
Donc il y a différentes façons de de
voir de voir tout ça. Euh moi la
question que que je soulève généralement
quand on a ces propositions, c'est euh
elles viennent de qui ? Elles sont
portées par qui et elles vont être
implantées par qui ? parce que tout le
monde peut avoir des bonnes idées et
elles peuvent ne jamais être prises en
compte par les élites, mais les élites
peuvent s'emparer de bonnes idées et les
et les les instaurer mais à leur à leur
à leur manière et pour leur intérêt
aussi. Donc il faut se poser ces
questions aussi. Je pense qu'on a des
bonnes idées euh parce qu'on peut avoir
des bonnes idées pendant 100, 200, 300
ans et que ça que ça devienne jamais des
des des idées reprises par le par le
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
ce qui l'intéresse, c'est pas juste des
bonnes idées, c'est des idées qui
l'aident à régler des problèmes et euh
garder son pouvoir.
Oui, ben c'est c'est la même chose. et
et donc
mais c'est sûr que dans des régimes
parlementaires, il y a des sortes de
régimes qui sont plus intéressant que
d'autres d'un point de vue de la
répartition du pouvoir, la
représentation de la diversité, les
équilibres et cetera. Il y a des il y a
des régimes parlementaires qui ont des
cours suprêmes, d'autres qui en ont pas,
qui ont des chartes des droits de
liberté, d'autres qui en ont pas, qui
ont des systèmes multipartistes, des
élections à double tour, un tour
proportionnel et cetera. Donc, on
pourrait imaginer l'intégration d'un
système euh par tirage au sort. Il y a
différentes propositions. Euh,
généralement quand on parle de tirage au
sort, c'est euh ça a beaucoup d'avantage
par rapport à la à la diversité de qui
siègerait. Disons on imagine une
assemblée, disons en France, il y aurait
disons l'Assemblée nationale, disons
qu'on garde le Sénat, je sais pas
pourquoi. Et puis et puis il y aurait
une autre chambre qui serait tirée au
sort ou une partie de l'Assemblée
nationale serait tirée au sort. Je
j'invente un système. Donc ces gens de
cirort, il y a plusieurs avantages par
rapport au système électoral.
Premièrement, généralement, ils sont
plus ils sont plus diversifiés. Euh
donc, il y a pas que des millionnaires,
des gens gros et bons. Exactement. Donc
déjà ça peut être intéressant. et les et
les et les exercices qui ont été faits
avec du tirage au sort sur des
réflexions sur par exemple le système de
santé ou d'autres montrent généralement
que quand on a des assemblées comme ça,
tendantiellement disons que leur leur
leurs choix sont plus progressistes,
plus plus égalitaires euh parce que
c'est des gens plus diversifiés, c'est
des gens aussi, appelons-le, du peuple
ou des classes moyennes ou des classes
moyennes défavorisées aussi. Donc il y a
des éditions qui se disent "Ben, il me
semble ça serait plus juste comme ça
quoi." Donc ça c'est la première chose.
La deuxième chose c'est que pour être
pour être tiré au sort, vous n'avez pas
besoin d'un parti, vous n'avez pas
besoin d'argent et vous pouvez pas être
corrompu. À moins vraiment quelqu'un
veut jouer à la loto, il pense que vous
vous allez tirer au sort, donc je vous
donne 200 € en disant "C'est quand tu
seras tiré au sort, je veux que tu me
redonnes quelque chose." Mais évidemment
ça fonctionne pas comme ça puisque le
tirage au sort par par définition, c'est
complètement aléatoire. Donc ça évite la
corruption, ça évite les promesses euh
aux petits amis. euh puisqu'on ne sait
pas qu'on va être tir au sort et tout à
coup on est tir au sort. Donc ça c'est
un gros avantage parce que la corruption
elle est évidemment euh corruption
légale hein des fois d'ailleurs elle est
elle est elle est là dans le système
dans le système électorel, il la
favorise d'une certaine manière. Euh et
puis une fois qu'on est tiré au sort,
les expériences qui ont été faites euh
parce que souvent la critique du tirage
au sort c'est Ouais ouais mais là ça va
être vraiment n'importe quoi. Parce que
généralement les gens pas généralement
mais souvent les gens font vraiment
confiance aux élites politiques en
pensant que vraiment elles connaissent
mieux que nous ce qui est bon pour nous
dans tous les domaines. Je reviens au
sport, à la guerre, à l'économie, à la
culture et cetera. Alors que moi, je
pense que les élites politiques, la leur
vraie spécialité, c'est de prendre le
pouvoir. C'est c'est là-dedans qu'elles
sont bonnes. La preuve, c'est qu'elles y
sont. Et il y en a qui ont mis des
années, des dizaines d'années de leur
vie à arriver en haut. Là, ils en ont
mis des efforts, ils y arrivent pas par
hasard. Donc, ils sont bons là-dedans
là. Euh,
valer des sabres hein.
Exactement. Et donc après ça, est-ce que
ça ça veut dire qu'ils sont bons pour
euh réfléchir au système d'éducation ou
de santé et cetera ? Je sais pas. Mais
donc nos gens ti au sort généralement
dans les dans les modèles qui sont
proposés, ils ne vont pas simplement
s'asseoir et voter comme ça et prendre
des décisions sur tout et n'importe
quoi. N'importe quand. Euh il y a tout
un système de planification dans le
système de tirage au sort où les gens
tirés au sort euh pour discuter de tel
ou tel ou tel enjeu vont généralement
avoir recevoir des experts. Euh
généralement, on se dit il faut que ce
soit des experts qui ont plusieurs
points de vue, donc pas juste deux
experts qui ont un point de vue. Euh ils
vont pouvoir les les contre les
contrequestionner, ils vont pouvoir se
s'informer, se documenter, faire des
sous-groupes éventuellement et
finalement arriver à des à des
décisions. Et comme je vous dis, les les
quelques enquêtes que j'ai consulté sur
ce type de fonctionnement donnent
généralement des politiques plus
progressistes que que le système
électoral.
On va passer à quelques questions
internet.
Première qui me tombe devant les yeux,
que pensez-vous des votations de Suisse
?
Donc là, on arrive au référendum du
coup. Alors
ça tombe bien, j'ai passé de mois en
Suisse à l'automne, donc à Genève. Donc
j'ai mangé du chocolat et de la fondue
et euh
et euh et j'ai pas acheté de montre et
euh
vous avez fumé des gros cigares
non plus. Et euh mais plus sérieusement
euh
en fait c'est un système plus
intéressant que je pensais à priori en
parlant avec les collègues, avec les
gens là-bas, en regardant aussi parce
que c'était novembre, c'est une période
d'initiative populaire. Donc en Suisse,
pour les personnes qui le savent pas,
désolé pour celles qui le savent déjà,
en fait c'est un système plus diversifié
que je pensais. Il y a les initiatives,
les initiatives populaires si on peut
dire qui là viennent de la société
civile. Ça peut venir des partis, ça
peut venir d'organisation non
gouvernementale, mais disons ça ne vient
pas des des élus et et ça peut porter
sur un peu tout et n'importe quoi. Et
puis après ça, il y a l'obligation dans
le système suisse pour les élus
d'organiser des référendums.
Donc de soumettre à la population,
au votes de la population des décisions
qui consistent par exemple, si j'ai bien
compris, il a des décisions qui ont un
impact sur le budget, sur la fiscalité,
évidemment sur la Constitution. Donc et
aussi dans les référendums, il peut y
avoir des contestations de ce qui est
débattu
au niveau des des débats législatif.
Donc il y a deux structures. Il y a la
structure d'initiative populaire qui
vient vraiment de la base et puis après
ça, il y a ce qui tourne autour de ce
que discutent les élus.
Et dans certains cas donc la population
suisse peut se prononcer sur ce que
discutent les élus ou peut se prononcer
sur ce que propose la société civile.
Avec ce avec ce avec ce ce mode de
fonctionnement, il y a différents
effets.
Il y a des effets qui sont selon moi,
selon selon selon mes valeurs, disons
euh ou selon mes priorités politiques
qui sont des effets plus positifs et des
effets plus négatifs. les effets
positifs, c'est que
effectivement les gens peuvent
participer plus directement des
décisions qui les concernent
et que contrairement à ce qu'on pense,
ils ne prennent pas toujours des
décisions conservatrices parce que
souvent quand on mentionne le cas de la
Suisse, on va dire "Ah bah oui, mais
vous voyez, ils ont voté contre ceci ou
contre cela." Donc en fait la démocratie
directe ça donne toujours des ça donne
toujours le l'avantage au aux forces
conservatrices. Mais quand on observe
plus attentivement ce qui se passe en
Suisse qui est par ailleurs un pays
conservateur, donc évidemment il y a il
faut savoir aussi où on est, euh ben en
fait ils prennent pas toujours des
décisions conservatrices. Des fois oui,
des fois non. C'est pas toujours il y a
des il y a des diversités linguistiques
aussi en Suisse. Des fois c'est la
majorité linguistique qui impose sa
décision mais des fois non aussi. des
fois il y a il y a un effet de tolérance
ou de pluralisme. Donc c'est parce qu'en
fait pendant des semaines et des et des
mois la population suisse peut débattre
évidemment de de ces enjeux. Ils ont des
ils ont des on leur présente des on leur
présente des
des arguments cour des arguments pour
des arguments contre et on pourrait même
intégrer dans le système de référendum
initiative populaire un système mix avec
le tirage au sort. C'est-à-dire, je
m'explique, je pense que d'ailleurs
c'était c'est c'est une tentative, un
projet pilote en ce moment dans des
cantons. Euh on a tiré au sort quelques
citoyens, disons 20 24 chose rien euh
qui réfléchissent au sujet de telle
questions référendaires et en fait qui
vont présenter à la population après
avoir parlé des experts, après avoir
réfléchi au truc les de façon objective
entre guillemets les arguments pour et
les arguments contre. En plus, il y a un
camp du oui mais qui est évidemment
intéressé. Il y a un candid qui est
évidemment intéressé qui présente des
argumentaires mais ils sont en train de
tester si en plus on peut pas avoir une
sorte de d'agrégation de citoyens
indépendamment de oui ou du non qui vont
présenter des argumentaires pour et
contre. Donc il y a moyen d'avoir un
système d'initiative populaire où on
atteint quand même un bon niveau de
capacité autoréflexive de débat de
délibération sur sur les enjeux. Et moi
je trouve ça quand même plutôt
intéressant dans le cadre dans le cadre
dans le cadre actuel. C'est pas c'est
pas miraculeux, c'est pas et dans les
effets dans les effets pervers, cela dit
par contre de mon point de vue, c'est
qu'en fait les Suisses de ce fait on
accorde une très grande
légitimité à ces décisions puisqu'elles
sont prises par la population et ça a un
effet négatif sur leur perception qu'ils
ont de la légitimité des mouvements de
rue ou des des des mobilisations
sociales, des mouvements sociaux parce
se disent ben nous en fait les Suisses,
on peut dire, on peut prendre nos
décisions directement dans le système et
donc les gens qui sont dans la rue là,
c'est un peu c'est un peu c'est un peu
turbulent pour rien. On a un système qui
qui qui permet de de transcender de
transcender la forme politique de la de
la mobilisation du ou du mouvement
social. Et dernièrement en Suisse, si je
me trompe pas, ils ont même pris des
décisions sous forme d'initiative euh
pour encadrer encore plus fortement les
manifestations de rue avec des
obligations de de permis de
d'encadrement policier et même des
groupes de gauche et d'extrême gauche,
c'est bien compris, se plient à ce à à
ces nouveaux règlements qui limitent le
droit de manifester parce qu'ils disent
bah c'est une décision de la population
donc on accepte ça.
Double question euh qui les doubles de
deux questions qui vont arriver. Euh en
France, on a passé une loi sur les
casseurs.
Oui.
Vous en avez entendu parler
des casseurs ? Oui.
Non, de la loi.
La loi sur les casseurs. Je l'ai pas lu
attentivement, mais oui, j'ai vu. Oui.
D'accord. Et la deuxième qui va venir
juste après, est-ce qu'il faudrait avoir
un temps démocratique pour que chaque
personne puisse s'intéresser à la chose
publique ? Oui. Donc euh
la question du temps, ça on l'avait
abordé trop rapidement tout à l'heure.
Euh ces deux questions intéressantes et
qui sont vraiment différent, donc je les
prends. Euh donc malheureusement, j'ai
pas lu le le texte précément de la loi
contre les casseurs. Donc ça va être
difficile pour Je sais pas si la
question euh attendait de moi comme un
avis juridique ou une évaluation
vraiment de la loi. Euh
les les des lois sur les casseurs, il y
en a déjà il y en a déjà plein. Le
l'État que ce soit l'État français,
canadien, américain, britannique et
cetera, ils ont tout un arsenal pour
pour punir ce qu'on appelle les casseurs
qui qui est un terme d'ailleurs
évidemment foncièrement péjoratif. Euh
à l'époque de la Révolution française,
on les aurait appelé les patriotes ou
les révolutionnaires ou les
républicains, mais aujourd'hui on les
appelle les casseurs. C'est quand même
c'est quand même évidemment un terme
dénigrant. Il y a des casseuses aussi
d'ailleurs. Euh mais euh
mais ils en ont déjà plein de de lois de
lois pour euh c'est c'est quand même
déjà illégal là de lancer un pavé dans
une ville de banque là. C'est pas c'est
pas c'était pas illégal avant là. Et
donc ça c'est simplement de de la
consolidation de la de la densification
des
et évidemment c'est une opération c'est
une opération évidemment politique. À la
limite ça donne peut-être quelques
nouveaux outils euh euh à la police pour
justifier des interventions. Je pense
que la police française, je pense
qu'elle est très très généreusement
fournie en en terme de moyen de de
d'intervenir, d'infiltrer, de faire des
arrestations préventives, de mettre en
garde de vue de on l'a vu là depuis des
années, ils ont c'est comme pour les
lois antiterroristes en France là, vous
êtes rendu à 18e stratification de loi
antiterroriste là, je pense que c'est
bon là vous mais il c'est c'est bien de
toujours en refaire parce que ça montre
gagner la guerre contre le terrorisme
et contre les casseurs, c'est bien de
montrer que le gouvernement vraiment
fait quelque chose. Donc il a il en
rajoute, il en rajoute, il en rajoute,
il en rajoute, il en rajoute.
Le temps,
le temps,
le temps, c'est euh
le temps, c'est la grande oubliée des
débats démocratiques, je pense
aujourd'hui euh
le temps, c'est ce qui nous manque
généralement euh pour faire de la
politique et pour faire de la politique
dans le bon sens du terme, pas pour
mener une campagne. Et
le manque de temps fait penser que
justement les élections c'est un bon
système parce qu'en fait c'est une fois
tous les 4 ans et il y a rien de plus
simple que de les voter. Ça peut prendre
5 10 minutes si c'est pas trop loin de
chez vous et si la file est pas trop
longue. Et vous pensez que pendant ce
temps-là, c'est bon, les quatre
prochaines années, il y a quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de vos affaires pour vous que
vous êtes libre. Libre de faire quoi ?
Libre d'aller travailler, libre
éventuellement d'avoir un weekend avec
des amis, libre d'avoir du temps avec
votre copine, avec votre famille et
cetera. Et vous pensez que la liberté,
c'est ce temps-là. C'est le c'est ce
qu'on appelle le temps libre. Et souvent
euh on en arrive à penser que quand on
doit s'engager politiquement, les
assemblées par exemple, on va dire c'est
une perte de temps.
Et c'est décourageant qu'on pense comme
ça parce que c'est le moment où on fait
de la politique où selon moi on peut
être vraiment libre politiquement et
libre politiquement c'est dans un cadre
qui est encore très coercitif mais où où
on est dans l'action politique ensemble
que souvent on pense qu'on qu'on perd du
temps et c'est assez décourageant et je
sais que pour en avoir fait des dizaines
et des centaines des assemblées
politiques, des assemblées syndicales,
des assemblées militantes, ça peut être
effectivement très long, des fois
ennuyeux, des fois inefficace. et des
fois arriver à des des conclusions qui
sont pas celles qu'on espère. Ça, je je
suis tout à fait conscient. Je je dis
pas que que c'est le truc le plus joyeux
et le plus drôle tout le temps les
assemblé, mais moi j'ai rarement
considéré que c'était une perte de
temps. Je pense qu'en fait c'est c'est
là où on peut on peut vraiment vivre la
politique concrètement et il nous il
nous manque il nous manque de ce
temps-là. Mais ce qui nous manque aussi,
je dirais et c'est peut-être ça va
peut-être ensemble,
c'est qu'en fait les les les nos
activités politiques, elles vont nous
sembler d'autant plus vaines ou d'autant
plus des pertes de temps que en fait
dans notre vie, on contrôle pas
grand-chose.
Et donc c'est pour ça que dans les
mouvements sociaux et j'inclus làdedans
les mouvements les mouvements syndicaux
par exemple,
les assemblées, elles sont pleines et
elles sont intenses et à la limite elles
sont intéressantes quand il y a vraiment
un enjeu, quand une grève s'en vient ou
quand quelque chose va vraiment avoir un
impact sur notre vie. Là, les gens
viennent aux assemblées, ont envie de
parler, ont envie de débattre et ont
envie éventuellement d'agir. Il y en a
qui peuvent être contre là, mais ont
envie, c'est là que ça se passe. Et euh
moi, pour être dans un syndicat euh lié
à mon travail, ben c'est sûr que quand
il y a pas de conflit de travail, les
assemblées sont à peu près vides parce
qu'en fait on on ne s'assemble pas pour
le plaisir de s'assembler non plus. il
faut qu'il y ait un sens à cette
assemblée. Et donc si on avait plus de
plus de commun à gérer ensemble entre
nous euh que ce soit lié d'ailleurs au
travail ou à la vie en fait la
production de la vie euh je pense que là
on trouverait un sens et à la limite
même un plaisir à se rassembler ensemble
et à faire de la politique ensemble. On
prendrait ce temps-là parce qu'on aurait
l'impression que ça aurait un sens
puisque ça serait notre vie en commun
dont nous serions en train de discuter.
Mais dans la mesure où nous sommes
dépossédé de notre vie en commun, que
nous connaissons pas nos voisins, que le
trottoir est pas à nous, la rue est pas
à nous, le bâtiment est pas à nous,
notre travail est pas à nous parce qu'il
est au patron, ben c'est vrai que on se
demande pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi on se
réunirait pour parler de quoi de toute
façon et donc pour sauver du temps entre
guillemets, on on va voter puis on se
dit ben ils vont s'occuper ils vont
s'occuper de nos affaires. C'est ce qui
se passe avec l'écologie là. L'écologie
on voit pas tout à fait les
répercussions dans la vie de la pleb et
après moi le déluge et on prend pas le
temps de se pencher sur ce sujet là.
Oui, le déluge c'est sans doute le bon
terme. Ouais.
Ouais. Bon question d'internet.
Pensez-vous qu'il y a une haine du
peuple chez les pères fondateurs de la
démocratie ?
Macron quand François Hollande disait
les 100 dents.
Oui, les 100 c'était bon ça.
C'est bon ça
c'est c'est breuveté. C'est
Mais à l'inverse, Étien de la Boessie,
philosophe du 7e siècle, disait les
manges peuples pour parler des pour
parler des dirigeants et les mangent
peuples, ils ont des dents et ils
mangent le peuple. Et oui, ben merci
pour la question. Euh donc la peur du
peuple, c'est ça ou la haine du peuple ?
La haine du peuple.
Le non respect, la peuple. Mais mais
elle est elle est fondamentale. Et le
problème ben pas le problème, un des
problèmes en plus c'est que c'est haine
du peuple. Elle nous est aussi
inculquée. Elle est elle est on l'en
partage parfois entre nous. Euh
dans un autre livre, si je peux me
permettre, je suis désolé de faire de
l'autopromotion, c'est un peu c'est un
peu bête, mais euh donc j'ai écrit un
autre livre qui s'appelle La peur du
peuple. Donc j'en parle parce que c'est
vraiment lié à cette question. Et j'ai
proposé deux concepts qui s'appelle
l'agoraphobie politique et l'agoraphilie
politique. Et c'est lié à ce que je
racontais il y a très longtemps
maintenant sur la transformation du mot
démocratie en deux trois générations.
Dans la mesure où moi je travaillais sur
le mot sur comment les les forces
politiques avaient modifié le mot
démocratie, moi-même j'avais de la
difficulté à utiliser le mot démocratie
et antidémocratisme dans mon dans mon
dans dans mes commentaires et dans mon
analyse parce que le mot avait plus le
même sens
à la 10e page de mon bouquin et à la
100e page. Donc là, j'étais comme mince,
je veux dire je veux dire quelque chose
de précis mais le mot a changé de sens.
Donc là, j'ai j'ai piraté en fait la
psychologie et je leur ai je leur ai
récupéré le terme d'agoraphobie
politique parce que ce que je voulais
désigner, c'était vraiment cette peur
phobie, ça évoque la peur mais en fait
c'est aussi une haine, c'est un mépris,
c'est un dédain pour les gens du peuple
quand ils sont assemblés. Donc l'agora,
l'agoraphobie et l'agoraphilie, c'est
une sorte d'amour ou d'émotion positive
quand le peuple est assemblé. Et donc je
pense fondamentalement que dans notre
philosophie politique, dans l'idéologie
dominante, dans la culture dominante, il
y a effectivement une sorte de
d'agorophobie politique, c'est-à-dire de
peur du peuple, de phobie du peuple, de
mépris du peuple de la part des élites,
surtout quand le quand le peuple est
assemblé, quand le peuple se rassemble,
que ce soit pour discuter ou pour agir,
des fois c'est sous forme des meutres ou
ou des fois c'est on commence par
s'assembler puis on on prend la rue.
Euh les élites ont peur, les élites ont
une haine de ce peuple et euh et le
méprise. Et cette agarophobie politique,
elle est structurée par des arguments.
Et ces arguments, je pense, ils sont
assez
assez forts,
c'est-à-dire ils semblent convaincants.
Et le premier de tous, je pense qui
structure l'ensemble de l'ensemble du de
cette idéologie
agoraphobe, c'est que le peuple est
irrationnel
et
donc instabilité
donc instabilité, danger, folie euh
et donc il faut donter la bête,
les extrêmes,
il faut la domestiquer, il faut la
neutraliser et évidemment ça laisse
entendre Si on dit le peuple est
irrationnel, ça laisse entendre que
celui qu'il dit lui est rationnel. Et
cette rationnalité là, elle a quelque
chose de particulier. C'est-à-dire que
c'est une rationnalité ou c'est une
raison qui est liée à la capacité de de
d'identifier, de définir et de défendre
ce qu'on va appeler au sens très général
et des fois flou d'ailleurs le bien
commun. Et donc on va dire ce peuple il
est il n'est il n'est il n'est peut-être
qu'il est composé d'individus qui
individuellement sont raisonnables. Mais
le problème c'est que quand ils se
retrouvent ensemble c'est ça le problème
on dit c'est que quand ces individus se
retrouvent ensemble il y a un effet de
masse. Il une sorte d'intelligence de de
d'intelligence collective qui en fait
une sorte de de d'irrationnalité
collective de folie collective euh de
passion collective. Cette bête n'est
qu'émotion n'est que passion. Et ce
qu'elle veut c'est son petit bien
égoïste.
Gustave Lebont, ça vous parle ?
Exactement. La psychologie des masses,
c'est exactement ça. Foules.
La psychologie des foules. Exactement.
C'est très très lié à ça. Et euh et donc
et donc on dit donc ce ce peuple, il ne
faut pas qu'il s'assemble parce que
quand il s'assemble, il devient
dangereux et et c'est très concret. Il y
a des lois contre les attroupements
illégaux. Et euh à l'époque des de
l'esclavage euh dans les colonies
britanniques euh et aux États-Unis, il y
avait des lois qui interdisaient aux
esclaves de plusieurs maîtres de se
retrouver assemblés ensemble parce qu'
les maîtres avaient peur de ce de ces de
ces de ces attroupements. Les femmes ont
déjà été interdites de se de se
rassembler ensemble ou de former ce
qu'on appelait des sociétés ou des clubs
pendant la Révolution française de 1789
et après 1848 si je me trompe pas aussi.
Euh les jeunes des fois sont interdits
de se de s'assembler, de se de se
retrouver ensemble. Les ouvriers ont
souvent été interdits de s'assembler. On
ne veut pas que le peuple s'assemble.
Mais le prétexte pour ne pas pour ne pas
lui permettre de s'assembler, c'est euh
qu'il est de irrationnel.
Et donc, puisqu'il est irrationnel, on
va revenir à la question des démagogues.
Puisqu'il est irrationnel, il serait
donc d'autant plus vulnérable à la
démagogie. il se fait manipuler, il
n'est qu'une sorte de faction puisqu'il
ne tire que vers son ses propres
intérêts. Il ne tire que il ne pense
qu'à ses propres intérêts, pas au fameux
biens commun. Et euh
et voilà, ça c'est la c'est la
gorophobie politique, c'est la
structuration de la gorophobie politique
qui est évidemment selon moi une sorte
de propagande
de décélérébration des gens qui essayent
de nous convaincre. Et d'ailleurs, il y
a plusieurs gens du peuple qui qui qui
pensent ça, qui pensent qu'on qui
pensent que nous sommes collectivement
incapables de de raisons politiques, de
discuter politiquement, qui pensent que
les émotions c'est mauvais aussi en
politique, ce qui est tout ce qui
pourrait être un sujet de débat. Moi, je
pense que les émotions, c'est pas
toujours négatif et surtout qui laisse
malheureusement entendre que justement
nos élites, elles elles sont
raisonnables
et euh elles ne sont pas habitées par la
passion ou les émotions. Alors que moi,
je pense que les élites politiques,
elles sont avant tout habitées par une
passion très précise qui s'appelle la
soif du pouvoir.
Une petite mégalomanie en plus, non ?
Oui, ça vient avec.
Euh, autre question internet. Euh,
ça, on la pose. Ouais. Quel est le
niveau de conscience dans les sociétés
occidentales que la démocratie est du
marketing pour les pauvres ? Oui. Alors,
la bonne nouvelle, si c'est une bonne
nouvelle, euh je pense que en fait euh
malgré tous les efforts, tout à l'heure,
je parlais de l'endoctrinement des
élèves dans les écoles à voter, euh la
façon dont on nous explique l'histoire,
Athène, la démocratie, tout ça, les
équipes de marketing politique, euh
l'encouragement au vote.
Malgré tous ces efforts, ce qui est
incroyable euh ce qui est presque une
source d'espoir, c'est qu'en fait depuis
20 30 ans, les sondages montrent et
l'abstention est une des expressions de
de cela que les gens y croivent plus. Et
même en fait parmi les gens qui votent,
il y a beaucoup de gens qui votent à on
entend souvent je vote à reculon, je
vote en me bouchant le nez, je vote pour
le moins pire. Ils sont pas super
motivés là. Ils pensent pas que c'est
génial pour qui il votent en ce moment
et qu'est-ce que ça va donner. Et ça
c'est sans compter les 30 40 % des gens
qui simplement ne vont plus voter ou ne
votent pas. Et donc en fait je pense que
le système je pense que les je pense
qu'une majorité des gens sont pas dupes.
Je pense qu'une majorité des gens
pensent vraiment que cette élite que
nous ne vivons pas dans une réelle
démocratie. Peut-être qu'il manque pour
des raisons de temps d'éducation et
cetera, c'est pas de leur faute là de
connaissance anthropologique ou
historique qui leur ferait voir d'autres
d'autres modèles ou d'autres expériences
de démocratie. C'est correct. On leur
renseigne pas. Donc il faut
des exemples de pays représentatifs de
tout ça.
Oui. Ben ce que je disais tout à l'heure
un peu là comme il y a des il y a des
expériences de de d'organisation
collective à l'extérieur de l'Occident,
dans l'Occident et cetera. Donc
donc on peut être un peu désespéré parce
qu'on voit pas de d'autres modèles de la
la fameuse alternative. Mais moi, je
pense qu'une une grande partie des gens,
peut-être la majorité, sont pas dup et
et sont et c'est ce qu'on c'est ce que
les c'est ce que les élites appellent en
se désolant le cynisme. Euh mais le
cynisme en fait, c'est ell qui l'ont
provoqué.
Mais c'est quoi ? C'est c'est de la
résignation, c'est il tombe dans le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance. C'est
quoi ?
Mais le misérabilisme de l'impuissance,
je sais pas, c'est
égoïsme.
C'est péjorettef l'égoïsme. Je sais, je
sais pas non plus. C'est c'est correct
de pas savoir quelle est la solution.
Euh il y a techniquement il y a
peut-être pas de solution aujourd'hui.
Peut-être qu' sils sont conscients de ce
qui se passe que on se fait gouverner
par une petite clique à soif de pouvoir
mégalomane
complètement dans le déni ou dans
l'endoctrinement ou dans l'idéologie
totale. Bon s'ils sont conscients, ils
vont se voter avec le le nez bouché ou
ils vont faire un vote barrage, ils vont
faire un vot
mais s'il bougent pas, s'il restent chez
eux à regarder la télé la plus belle de
la vie, leur télénovela ou ou à regarder
announa ou des choses comme ça, c'est
quoi ?
Est-ce qu'on mérite les politiques qu'on
a ?
Non, moi je crois pas en cette phrase.
C'est un slogan rigolo. Mais je
c'est fou l'aveugle ou à ceux qui leur
crèvent les yeux ?
Mais je je j'y crois pas à ce à ce
slogan. Moi, je suis plus euh
je suis moins je suis moins critique de
des gens qui qui voient pas de solution
et qui sont dans notre sorte de Vous
avez vous avez parlé d'apathie. Euh
moi honnêtement euh et je vais donner
c'est probablement des très mauvaises
analogies là vous me relancerez si vous
trouvez que je me défile là. Mais euh
moi si j'avais été paysan au Moyen-Âge
et que le roi était corrompu et
m'imposer des taxes injustes et cetera,
est-ce que vraiment je me serais levé le
matin avec ma fau et j'aurais commencé à
attaquer le Seigneur et cetera puis de
jours après, je serais pendu sur la
place publique et mon corps serait en
train de pourrir bouffé par les corbeaux
? J'en sais rien. Il y a il y a plein de
gens qui savent qui vivent dans des
systèmes qui n'ont pas de sens, qui sont
injustes. Ils savent qu'ils se font
exploités. Ils savent qu'il travaillent
pour des gens qui les respectent pas.
Euh et il ils ont pas la ils voient pas
la solution. Il y a des raisons
objectives pourquoi ils voient pas la
solution. Et donc il y en a là-dedans
qui pour certaines raisons à tel moment
font du sabotage ou font de la
désobéissance ou ralentissent la
cadence. D'ailleurs, je pense qu'il y a
pas mal de monde qui travaillent moins
avec moins d'enthousiasme que si s'il
travaillaient pour eux ou pour leur
communauté. Il y a différentes manières
de de de pas trop participer au système
mais de de pas avoir la solution pour
changer le système individuellement ou
collectivement. Moi, je lance pas la
pierre à personne. Euh, c'est c'est pas
si facile. Moi, je c'est c'est pas je
dis pas de ça façon bien présente ou
quoi que ce soit, mais moi j'ai un
doctorat en sciences politiques. Je sais
pas c'est quoi la solution. J'ai des
idées. Je je on parlait tout à l'heure
des mouvements sociaux, on parlait
deinitiative populaires et cetera. On
voit des choses comme ça, mais en fait
les vraies grandes transformations dans
les sociétés euh dans les sociétés,
elles se sont rarement euh passé euh
parce que quelqu'un avec des amis avait
établi un plan de match et que d'ici 8
mois, on allait renverser le système et
créer quelque chose de mieux. C'est
vraiment comme ça que ça se passe. Il y
a une situation, on sait pas trop qui a
une idée où il s'est passé quelque
chose, il y a une interaction
internationale. Le régime est
déstabilisé à moné, il y a une une
crise,
le signe noir.
Ouais. Il y a une crise dans l'élite, ça
c'est important. Il faut que l'élite
aussi soit soit déstabilisé en très pas
juste déstabilisé par rapport à la
population mais que dans l'élite euh il
y a il y a des gens qui veulent vraiment
transformer parce que généralement quand
l'élite de droite et de gauche c'est la
même élite là quand l'élite elle se
tient les coudes face à face à une
tentative vraiment de déstabiliser le
système y compris le système économique
les forces policières tiennent l'armée
tient le système tient et même si vous
avez la meilleure stratégie la meilleure
idée vous avez lu les meilleurs ouvrages
vous risquez fortement de vous faire
écraser Les les gilets jaunes, c'est
c'est ceux qui ont décidé de mourir à
genou ou de mourir debout ?
Mourir avec des gilets jaunes en tout
cas. Mais et donc on va les voir ça, ils
vont attirer l'attention. Les gilets
jaunes, je sais pas euh bon, je moi je
suis à Montréal de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique. Euh je l'ai j'ai suivi le
mouvement de loin, donc je je n'en suis
pas expert. J'ai pas été dans des
réunions de rond-point ou dans les
manifestations au Champs-Élysée ou à
Bordeaux ou ailleurs. Donc je suis
peut-être pas la meilleure personne pour
en parler. Mais mais de loin, ce que je
peux vous dire si ça a une valeur
quelconque ou un intérêt quelconque,
c'est que ça semble quand même un
mouvement euh plutôt sympathique. Ça ça
ça semble le trivialiser un peu là alors
qu'il y a des choses importantes qui qui
se passent là. Euh euh pour moi c'est
intéressant euh très très clairement. Ce
qui est intéressant aussi je trouve
c'est toutes les stratégies pour le
démoniser ou pour le ridiculiser ou pour
le dénigrer. Ça c'est vraiment pour le
diviser aussi. Ça c'est vraiment
intéressant les les stratégies de
contrôle de
exemple. Ah mais il y en a il a y a il y
a plein d'exemples. Évidemment, il y a
eu il y a eu toute la question de la
violence. Donc le mouvement des gilets
jaunes, on est violent. On le répète, on
le répète, on le répète, on le répète.
Alors antisémite
et puis là après ça, au début il était
islamophobe, maintenant il est
antisémite. Il était à l'extrême droite,
après ça il y en a d'autres qui disent
qu'il était à l'extrême gauche. Il est
jamais parfait ce mouvement des gilets
jaunes. Il y a toujours un défaut. C'est
c'est souvent de celui-là qu'on parle y
compris de la violence. Alors que entre
vous et moi, je pense pas que la police
française a perdu beaucoup d'eux ou de
doigts ou de mains ou de pieds depuis le
début des gilets jaunes alors que les
gilets jaunes, je pense qu'ils en ont
perdu pas mal. Donc au niveau de la
violence, il y a toujours cette espèce
de d'hypocrisie que la violence c'est
toujours c'est toujours celle du peuple
et jamais celle de l'État. Alors que
techniquement la violence de l'État est
tellement plus brutale, puissante et et
et légitime et en toute impunité.
Au Canada, on parle de ces fameuses
violences policières qu'on a sur notre
population par la police.
Au Canada, on en parle un peu. On parle
on parle, on a parlé des gilets jaune
mais comme n'importe quel là où je parle
des médias de des médias qu'on appelle
des médias de masse comme n'importe quel
médiat de masse quand on parle de choses
qui se passent à l'extérieur du pays, il
y a un effet de désintérêt qui
s'installe à moment donné quand quelque
chose quand un phénomène dure trop
longtemps. Je dis pas qu'il dure trop
longtemps dans le sens il devrait avoir
arrêté mais pour les médias c'est sûr
que là les gilets jaunes l'intérêt a
beaucoup baissé après disons janvier là
on en parle on en parle de moins en
moins. Puis a quelques reportages sur
les sur les violences policières, mais
bon, ça se passe ici hein, ça se passe
pas au Canada, donc nécessairement il y
a un effet de au Québec, il y a toujours
un intérêt pour ce qui se passe en
France parce qu'on est une ancienne
colonie. Donc il y a le il y a il y a
une sorte de syndrome de complexe
post-colonial. On se sent quand même
toujours lié à on on a on n pas de
reporter en Belgique ou en Espagne ou en
Italie, mais la France, on veut toujours
savoir ce qui se passe en France parce
que c'est les anciennes métropoles. Mais
là bon, même pour nos médias
postcoloniaux à moné les gilets jaunes,
ça dure depuis un peu trop longtemps.
Donc moi, je m'informe en ayant voir des
articles sur lundi matin ou sur des
sites comme ça.
Trudeau c'est un petit Macron.
C'est Macron qui est un petit trouau.
Euh
qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire sur
Justin Trudeau ? Justin Trudeau, c'est
une belle opération de marketing.
Mais si je voulais être un peu généreux
avec lui, si je me permets d'être un peu
généreux avec lui, je dirais qu'il a
qu'il a de de par sa famille, de par
vous savez qu'il est le fils d'un ancien
premier ministre aussi canadien Pierre
Lot Trudu. Donc c'est c'est dans la
famille. Donc on revient à la question
du pouvoir formel et informel. C'est
quand même pas un hasard. et il a
beaucoup joué sur son nom Trudo. Le le
père était une personnalité très haute
en couleur. Et Justin Trudeau vient
vraiment d'un milieu libéral mais pas
dans le sens français. Libéral dans le
sens
anglo-saxon. C'està dire libéral aussi
au niveau moral et culturel. Euh le
libéral au niveau moral et culturel dans
le milieu anglo-saxon, c'est celui qui
dit qui fait ce qu'il vient de faire. Il
vient de légaliser le cannabis par
exemple. Euh il est dans des
manifestations gay lesbiennes, trans. Il
y croit réellement. C'est pas juste
l'opération de de marketing politique.
Il croit vraiment que les gens devraient
pouvoir vivre leur sexualité ou avoir
l'identité sexuelle qu'ils veulent. Donc
ça c'est ça. Je pense qu'ils croient
vraiment euh à ça. Euh les libéraux au
Canada, ils sont pour l'immigration.
On la contrôle cette immigration. On est
pas c'est pas les portes grandes
ouvertes de toute façon nous où on est
on est placé on est bien protégé des des
on a l'Atlantique et le Pacifique et et
l'Arctique. Donc ça va là et et en
dessous c'est les États-Unis. Donc
évidemment nos nos débats sur
l'immigration, ils sont ils sont
géostratégiquement positionnés dans un
endroit où les les réfugiés ont beaucoup
de difficultés à nous rejoindre mais on
a quand même des débats et les libéraux
tendantiellement sont plutôt pour
l'immigration dans une perspective
humanitaire un peu mais
mais surtout le travail surtout le
travail c'est des libéraux dans le sens
le libre marché ils vont venir ils vont
s'intégrer au ils vont s'intégrer au
travail et c'est bien et c'est bien il
est pour la diversité culturelle et
cetera ça c'est trudeau.
Par ailleurs, Trudo est aussi un premier
ministre et un politicien du Parti
libéral qui est un parti qui a toujours
été près des grandes banques de Toronto,
du capital financier. Donc il il y est.
Et là, Trudeau c'est un politicien qui
est élu et donc il doit il doit penser à
sa à sa base électorale de l'ouest du
Canada. Et à l'ouest du Canada, vous en
avez peut-être entendu parler, il y a
des immenses projets de pipeline et
d'oloduc. Et Trudeau qui se présentait
comme un politicien plutôt cool, vert
environnementaliste et biodégradable,
ben en fait, il a fait des deals avec
les les les grandes compagnies. Il a mis
de l'argent public, des milliards de
dollars pour des des
pipelines et des des olioduc. qui là, il
est vraiment en bataille et il est
vraiment pris à parti
environnementalistes, les écologistes et
les groupes autochtones
traditionnalistes qui occupent des des
territoires ancestraux autochtones pour
bloquer des
des le passage la construction de de
l'éoduc. Donc pour finir là-dessus,
Justin Trudeau se présentait aussi comme
le premier ministre qui allait
qui allait enfin permettre une vraie
réconciliation entre les sous celles
qu'on appelle les premières nations,
donc les peuples autochtones et et la
nation canadienne anglaise et canadienne
française. donc dans un processus un peu
de décolonial, il proposait des des des
grandes commissions de réconciliation,
une enquête publique sur les femmes
autochtones assassinées disparues. Il y
en a des milliers de femmes autochtones
assassinées disparues pour lesquels les
la les les corps policiers accordent la
dernière des priorités. Donc c'est un
scandale c'est un scandale national. Il
y a plein de manifestations de
mobilisation de autochtones, femmes
autochtones et d'alliés qui disent
"Ouais, mais les femmes autochtones,
c'est vraiment les dernières des
dernières des dernières, vous leur
raccordez aucune importance."
Euh et euh et Trudeau a mis ça en place
pour montrer qu'il était un bon un bon
canadien qui va être gentil avec les
avec les autochtones. Mais en même
temps, il il là, il commence à faire
expulser des des camps d'occupation des
des occupations militantes tenues par
des autochtones sur des terres
ancestrales pour pour bloquer lesques.
Donc il c'est un politicien.
Macron. Donc c'est la même chose en plus
petit.
Euh autochtones, on a moins le problème.
Oui oui mais je pense que Macron, il est
même
c'est c'est une compétition nationaliste
un peu ridicule ce que je suis en train
de faire mais je pense que Macron Macron
il est même moins cool que Justin Trudo.
Ben nous on a pas mais bon après ça
après ça après ça on s'en fout un peu de
de comparer de comparer les deux mais
ils sont un peu dans le même style. Oui
quand même les jeunes Golden Boy.
Ouais. Euh on arrive vers la fin de
notre interview. Est-ce que vous avez un
sujet à aborder comme ça ? Mon dieu,
c'est ça la question là ?
Non non non, on vous réinvitera euh euh
pour euh le complexe de l'homme par
rapport au féminisme.
Oui.
Et si vous voulez en parler un petit
peu, euh
je peux ouvrir ouvrir là-dessus mais
vraiment euh rapidement parce que là ça
ça mériterait d'autres d'autres
développements.
Petit apéritif introduction.
Exactement. Donc euh donc ça c'est
totalement un autre type de de
réflexion, même si dans même si dans mes
livres sur euh sur euh sur la
démocratie, le livre sur le père du
peuple et tout, j'essaie quand même de
d'accorder une une importance ben
d'accorder une importance de voir
l'importance en fait qu'on qu'on
desmobilisation de femmes aussi, des
mobilisations féministes ou de femmes
dans des pratiques démocratiques euh
et souvent qui sont qui sont inconnus.
Euh je donne souvent l'exemple de pour
la capacité. Tout à l'heure, je vous
disais euh la démocratie c'est pas juste
Athène, la démocratie directe. Donc je
donne souvent l'exemple qui est assez
bien documenté des femmes Igbo au
Nigéria qui euh jusque dans les années
20, c'est un c'est une colonie euh
c'était administrée par les Anglais à
l'époque. Euh les femmes avaient euh
avaient leur assemblée de femmes. Donc
il y avait des assemblées du village où
les femmes et les hommes étaient en
assemblée parce qu'il y avait un dicton
igbo qui disait "L'intelligence n'est
pas de sexe. Donc vous fait être un
homme ou une femme et participer au aux
assemblées de village. Mais les femmes
avaient leur propre assemblée qui
duraient d'ailleurs des fois 2 tr jours
où elles parlaient entre elles de ce qui
concernait leur production agricole
parce qu'ils avaient des ils avaient et
les ventes de produits au marché mais
aussi comme elles étaient femmes, elles
pouvaient parler de violence de violence
masculine contre les femmes et on
connaît on connaît on on l'Occident
connaît assez bien le ben connaît assez
bien l'Occident étudié les ces cette
organisation politique des famigbau
parce qu'en 1929, il y a eu ce que les
Britanniques ont appelé la guerre des
femmes. Et la guerre des femmes, c'était
le résultat de
d'une pratique chez ses femmes quand il
y avait un homme qui était identifié
comme violent contre sa conjointe, les
femmes se se paraaient de leur tenue de
guerrière et se s'assemblaient autour de
l'homme ou de son de ce de sa résidence
et entenait des champs de guerre. Et
s'il ne s'excusait pas, s'il ne
promettait pas de d'arrêter ses
violences, elle faisait ce qu'elles
appelaient. C'est un terme un peu
bizarre en français, mais s'asseoir sur
l'homme, c'était elle détruisait sa elle
détruisait sa résidence.
Et en 1929, les femmes ont appris, on
sait pas trop si c'est une rumeur ou si
c'était vrai, mais elles ont appris en
fait que les les la puissance les
administrateurs britanniques avaient
décidé de d'imposer des nouvelles taxes
aux produits des marchés agricoles et
donc les famig pensaient qu'elles
seraient taxées pour leurs produits et
donc en apprenant cela, elles ont
convoqué leurs assemblées de femmes.
Elles se sont
elles ont revêtu leur leur tenue de
guerrière et en fait apparemment ce sont
des milliers de famillebbo qui ont
convergé vers les les bâtiments du
centre administratif britannique et elle
disait qu'elles allaient s'asseoir sur
l'homme britannique s'il ne renonçait
pas à ses à ses taxes.
Et donc là, c'est un bon exemple de
c'est un bon exemple de la capacité du
peuple de s'assembler. dans ce cas-ci,
c'est un peuple de femmes, de
s'assembler, de prendre des décisions
ensemble et d'agir ensemble. Donc là,
c'est une sorte de manifestation émeute
qu'elles ont organisé à cette époque et
euh dans un un monde en fait, le monde
des Higbo qui était en fait beaucoup
plus égalitaire que la Grande-Bretagne à
l'époque. Et euh
et évidemment les administrateurs
britanniques n'ont absolument rien
compris. Ils ont vu des femmes en tenue
de guerre qui hurlaient autour d'eux et
cetera. Donc, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
? Bah, ils ont sorti les mitraillettes
et ils ont tiré dans le tas et ils ont
jamais rien compris ce qui leur était
arrivé. De toute façon, ils ont gagné et
après ils ont tenu une commission
d'enquête puisque c'est la
Grande-Bretagne, c'est un pays civilisé,
ça tient des comités d'enquête après
avoir massacré des gens. Et donc, les
militaires sont venus s'expliquer et les
militaires, c'est incroyable. Il y a des
témoignages les militaires qui avaient
plusieurs militaires avaient fait la
Première Guerre mondiale et il disait
ces femmes diables ce n'était rien à
comparer les Allemands les BCH n'étaient
rien à comparer à ces femmes diablesses.
Nous n'avons jamais eu aussi peur. Il y
en avait qui avaient réprimé le
mouvement républicain irlandais. Il
disait c'était rien à comparer de ces
femmes igb des diablesses en feu en des
furies qui nous menaçaient de mort.
Elles voulaient nous déchiqueter. C'est
des femmes avec des sagets et des petit
boucliers de rien du tout. Ils les ont
ils les ont complètement euh
complètement complètement massacrés.
Zemour, c'est votre copain ?
Zemour, pas vraiment non. Sorel non plus
d'ailleurs, c'est pas Donc on revient là
vraiment la question de mon mon bouquin
sur le le la crise de la masculinité.
Donc euh et là je le fais vraiment
court. Donc dans mon livre sur la crise
de la masculiné qui vient de qui vient
de sortir ici en France euh j'essaie de
démontrer en fait que
en fait il y a ce discours de la crise
de la masculiné qu'on entend souvent.
qu'on entend partout qui est porté par
des porte-paroles comme Zemour.
Évidemment, il avait publié un livre qui
s'appelait Le premier sexe en 2006 qui
est exactement làdessus. Soral vers la
féminisation. Il y en a d'autres aux
États-Unis, en Angleterre, au Canada et
cetera. Et euh mais la thèse que
j'essaie de défendre dans ce livre,
c'est que le le la crise de masculiné en
fait, c'est un discours, ce n'est pas un
un fait social. Un discours est un fait
social évidemment, mais c'est c'est
vraiment un discours, c'est vraiment de
la rhtorique. Et pourquoi je dis ça ?
Parce que à travers des études
historiques, j'ai constaté qu'en fait en
Occident depuis au moins 500 ans, des
hommes vont dire qu'il y a une crise de
masculinité.
Au 16e siècle, c'est vrai, dans la la
cour d'Angleterre et la cour de France,
le roi lui-même des deux côtés de la
Manche, les autorités ecclésiastiques,
des auteurs de poèmes et de de pièces de
théâtre parlent de crise de masculiné.
On a ça pendant la Révolution française.
On a ça au 19e siècle aux États-Unis, en
Angleterre, en France, en Allemagne et
ailleurs. On est entre les deux guerres.
On est pendant la guerre froide. Et
aujourd'hui, en fait, j'ai trouvé des
études sur la crise de masculiné à peu
près partout au Bangladesh, en Corée, au
Japon, en Russie. En Russie, on veut pas
me faire croire que les féministes
contrôlent la Russie là. Les Py Riot
auraient plus le contrôle du Crémelin,
c'est pas sérieux. Au Mexique, au
Maghreb, en France évidemment, aux
États-Unis et cetera. Et donc ce
discours, il est tellement euh
permanent, il est tellement universel
que selon moi, il ne peut pas être autre
chose que de la rhtorique de la
propagande. Une sorte de déclaration de
panique face à n'importe quelle femme
qui ne tient pas son la place qu'on veut
qu'elle tienne et une sorte d'appel à
l'aide aux hommes qui disent "Ah, nous
sommes perdus, nous n'avons plus de
repère, nous n'avons plus de modèle,
nous sentons menacés par ces femmes qui
ne qui ne qui ne respectent pas leur
rôle que nous leur avons signé." Et donc
il faut d'une certaine manière
contre-attaquer. Et donc pour moi le
discours de la crise de masculiné c'est
profondément un discours antiféministe.
Mais là évidemment je je dis ça beaucoup
trop vite évidemment pour on se
voit en France
euh probablement à l'automne
on on se verra
en canau. Vous m'avez proposé de revenir
en cano. Donc
on verra la météo et tout. Peut-être je
ne survivrai pas mais mais avec un GPS
sur mon gilet de sauvetage vous pouvez
peut-être retrouver mon corps là.
Déconnez pas, j'ai un copain qui
s'appelle Kim FZ qui est parti de France
en Cano et kayak pour récupérer le
Canada. Il est arrivé,
il est arrivé.
Bon ben je j'irai prendre un café avec
lui.
Ouais, si on le retrouve
à l'automne. Je reviens à l'automne en
en principe, c'est pas sant.
Donc on prend tout de suite rendez-vous
pour le
ça me ferait vraiment plaisir. J'ai
c'est vraiment une super bonne dynamique
l'émission avec en plus toutes les
questions qui arrivent. Je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant.
Dernière question d'internet. Est-ce que
selon vous la non violence protège
l'État ? Quel regard historique
portez-vous sur l'efficacité de la
nonvolence ?
Ah c'est une bonne question. Je peux
faire une dernière promotion alors ?
Mais là, c'est même pas à moi, je j'en
tire aucun centime. Euh
donc, je soulligne l'apparution aux
édition libre de du livre de Peter
Gulderlous euh quand la nonvolence euh
protège l'État. Je pense c'est ça le
titre euh qui est une traduction de de
l'anglais. J'ai fait une petite préface
mais c'est le livre qui est intéressant.
Et donc
il y aurait vraiment beaucoup de choses
à dire sur cette question de violence et
non violence. Mais en tout cas, ce qui
est clair, c'est que euh si on reste
dans l'époque actuelle, c'estàdire la
dernière génération, disons de 68 à
aujourd'hui, les mouvements sociaux
progressistes, contestataires et cetera,
ils sont en permanence traversés par
cette question de violence, non
violence, ce débat violence, non
violence.
Mais quand on regarde attentivement, ce
qui est vraiment incroyable et dans la
préface, je pense, j'ai plusieurs
exemples, euh
ils ont une sorte de
d'exigence éthique ou de définition de
la violence qui est excessive et
totalement restrictive en terme de
moyens d'action. Et donc, j'ai retrouvé
au moins deux trois exemples où euh aux
États-Unis, en Italie et ailleurs, des
mobilisation
éclatent, des conflits extrêmement
graves éclatent dans des mobilisations
militantes parce que des militants
militantes voulaient apporter des
pinces.
Et donc on a vu ça en Italie contre le
mouvement qu'on appelle notave contre la
construction d'une ligne à haute vitesse
de train à haute vitesse. Un écrivain
italien s'est même fait accuser de
de encouragement au sabotage et je pense
au terrorisme et il faudrait vérifier
pour avoir dit qu'une pince c'est une
bonne idée parce qu'en fait l'idée c'est
de de couper des clôtures pour pouvoir
arriver sur les chantiers. Dans les
années 70, il y avait eu le même débat
sur la côte est américaine des euh le
clamshell alliance. C'est l'alliance de
la palourde. C'est un nom un peu bizarre
mais en fait c'est une alliance contre
la construction d'une centrale nucléaire
dont le dont les les écou dont qui
aurait provoqué en fait un réchauffement
de l'aburait aurait exterminé une
communauté de pas lourde. Donc des
militants avaient dit ben pour rentrer
sur le chantier, on va couper quand même
les la clôture. Euh et puis bon bref, il
y a d'autres exemples. Gunter Anders
donne des exemples aussi comme ça. Et
donc là, c'est ça, c'est de ça qu'on
parle le débat violence, non violence
dans les mouvements militants. Là, c'est
une une pince à ciseler une clôture d'un
réacteur nucléaire.
Ça c'est de la violence et il faut pas
faire ça parce que c'est de la violence,
ça nous discrédite. Et puis évidemment,
il y a la fameuse vitrine de banque.
Faut surtout pas casser les vitrines de
banque parce que ça c'est de la
violence. Et
et défoncer une porte de ministère avec
un transpalette,
c'est de la violence aussi parce que la
porte du ministère, elle est c'est elle
est sensible. euh des émotions à la
porte du ministère et euh et euh et
c'est et c'est et c'est incroyable quoi.
C'est comme une euh
c'est une attaque quand même sur la
République.
Ah mais je dis pas que mais je moi je
suis pas juriste, mais je sais très bien
que tout ça c'est illégal. C'est illégal
d'arriver avec la pince et de bah
d'arriver avec la pince non mais en tout
cas de couper la clôture, je sais que
c'est illégal mais c'est pas de ça qu'on
parle. c'est que les mouvements sociaux,
dans les mouvements sociaux, il y a des
gens qui sont tellement obsédés par la
nonviolence qui considèrent que ça c'est
de la violence. Ce qui est vraiment ce
sur quoi on pourrait avoir vraiment un
débat quand on regarde l'histoire du 20e
siècle et du 21e siècle.
Moi, je pense que dans 3 400 ans, s'il
reste si l'humanité est encore là, il y
a encore des historiens, des
historiennes, ils vont regarder ça, ils
vont ils vont ils vont ils vont se
pisser dessus tellement ils vont rire
qu'ils vont dire quoi ? C'est pas
sérieux là. Ils étaient pas en train de
débattre à savoir que ça c'était de la
violence là. Euh alors que pendant alors
que deux générations avant des
présidents un président des États-Unis
lançait des bombes atomiques sur des
villes que il y avait des camps de
concentration que il y avait comme ça
puis ça ils étaient en train de débattre
sur la violence. C'est sérieux ça ? Ils
se sont empris puis il y a des
coalitions qui ont éclaté à cause de ça.
C'est pas sérieux. On peut être contre
pour différentes raisons hein. On veut
pas prendre de risque. On va être
criminalisé et cetera, ça je comprends.
Mais le débat éthique violence et non
violence, il est il est vraiment euh euh
perverti dans les mouvements sociaux
avec en plus des exemples, des
références à des exemples qui sont tout
à fait mal compris. Et les deux exemples
tarte à la crème disons qu'on entend
souvent c'est Mat McGandy et Martin
Luther King. Donc on ça on les sort tout
le temps. On dit "Ah ben vous voyez la
nonviolence peut fonctionner parce que
Gandhi a libéré l'Inde par la
nonviolence et Martin Luther King euh
mis fin au racisme, je sais pas ce qu'il
a fait, déségrégué quelque chose aux
États-Unis par la nonvolence. Mais ça
c'est un c'est un c'est un c'est un
c'est une illusion complète pendant le
dans le mouvement d'indépendance
de l'Inde auquel participait Gandhi.
C'est vrai qu'il a émané des campagnes
de de désobéissance civile et et des
campagnes non violentes, mais dans le
même mouvement, il y avait des gens qui
attaquaient des casernes de l'armée
britannique avec des bombes et des
mitraillettes. C'est ça se passait en
même temps. Et pendant qu'il y avait
Martin Luther King qui marchait à
Birmingham dans la nonvolence en disant
il faut il ne faut pas être violent, ben
il y avait des Afhro-Américains qui
avaient des des des armes à feu et qui
se défendaient contre le Kaka qui menait
des qui a eu des dizaines et des
centaines d'émeutes. J'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure dans des dans des quartiers
afhro-américains
et euh et ça a été extrêmement violent
et outre le fait que je suis même pas
sûr que Martin Lutherking a gagné de
toute façon d'une certaine manière, il y
a encore énormément de racisme aux
États-Unis évidemment euh
il est il est impossible de de de
séparer ses formes de de d'action dans
ces mouvements dont on parle et dont on
pense que Martin Lutherking est le seul
représentant et que Gandy le seul
représentant. En fait, on ne sait pas si
seulement avec la non violence il serait
arrivé où ils sont arrivés, ce à quoi
ils ont arrivés. Mais ce qu'on sait,
c'est que les élites politiques aux
États-Unis, c'est un très bon exemple,
aux États-Unis, il y a maintenant un
jour férier qui s'appelle le Martin
Luther King D. Donc maintenant que c'est
fini, alors qu'on le présentait comme un
démon, un monstre, un dangereux
agitateur, maintenant qu'il est mort et
20 30 ans plus tard, les
l'État américain peut très bien avoir
une journée en l'honneur de Martin
Luther King, mais il y aura jamais une
journée en l'honneur de Malcomics.
Euh là, les paramètres économiques
et et juste pour terminer et juste pour
terminer la nonvolence de ces deux de
ces de de ces deux théoriciens de la
nonvolence euh implique de se faire
taper dessus.
C'est ça la non violence de de
Matandier de Martin Lutherking, c'est
d'avancer collectivement vers la police,
de forcer de transgresser les
transgresser la loi et l'objectif c'est
de se faire taper dessus et d'être filmé
en train de se faire taper dessus ou vu
en train de se faire taper dessus pour
montrer révéler en fait le niveau de
violence auquel est prêt à à s'adonner
la puissance coloniale ou la puissance
raciste dans le cas des États
États-Unis, c'est resté souci dans le
cas de l'Inde et cetera.
La puissance économique
et et qui est lié à la puissance
économique évidemment. Et en en faisant
ça, on on déchire le voile de la
présendue prétention civilisationnelle
ou je sais pas trop quoi de de l'élite.
C'est ça la nonvolence. La non violence,
c'est pas juste de se promener avec une
chandelle ou une fleur et cetera et de
dire paix
fin à la guerre du Vietnam ou je ne sais
pas trop quoi. C'est de c'est c'est
c'était une non violence offensive. On a
on a très rarement ça aujourd'hui quand
on parle de ces débats-là dans les
mouvement soci de la nonvoliolence de
bobo
là les paramètres économiques euh bon on
étudie quelques paramètres économiques
sur cette chaîne YouTube. Euh
consommation énergétique, produits
dérivés, produits financiers et tout
tout ce jargon là pour décrire les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité.
Ces paramètres sont en train de se
dégrader apparemment. Oui.
Euh vitesse grand V. La question que je
vais vous poser, c'est est-ce que le
peuple va réclamer un Kaiser
comme ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire
à chaque fois que les paramètres
économiques ou les paramètres d'accès à
la à la calorie, accès à la nourriture,
accès donc au travail
Oui.
se dégradait.
Je sais pas si ça s'est reproduit à
chaque fois dans l'histoire, mais ça
s'est reproduit à certaines fois dans
l'histoire. Oui, effectivement. Est-ce
que les gens vont réclamer un Kaiser et
par ce mécanisme
d'émagogie de de scultage de fumée de
brassage d'air chaud politicienne pour
leur faire miré que demain ça ira mieux
?
On va vers la dictature, on va sur des
gouvernements autoritaires, on va sur
euh
Bon, le Kaiser c'est c'est allemand.
Donc, vous pouvez parler d'un maréchal
euh ou d'un de d'un d'un caporal puisque
vous avez eu Bonapart et le maréchal,
mais euh
voilà,
mais euh chaque pays a ses aes à ses
images. Euh,
il faut dire avec l'accent, un car.
Oui, j'imagine, ça fait encore plus
effrayant. Euh
à part pour la question euh euh de
dégradation euh climatique qui me semble
euh tellement évidente aujourd'hui, même
si plusieurs personnes l'avaient vu
depuis au moins deux trois générations.
Euh moi j'hésite beaucoup à faire des
projections sur 10 15 20 ans. Là euh il
y a tellement de collègues, c'est bon,
c'est pas grave de m'humilier qu'on me
qu'on me remonte un extrait de vidéo
dans 15 ans, c'est ça serait pas très
grave. Mais surtout si si c'est parce
qu'il y a un dictateur ou pas dictateur,
c'est plus important que mon propre égo.
Mais mais c'est simplement d'un point de
vue comme d'honnêteté intellectuel, je
les ai toujours
anticipé qu'est-ce qui va arriver dans
10 15 ans. Surtout des grosses
transformations de ce type.
Mais exactement, c'est ce que j'allais
dire. Mais est-ce que c'est quelque
chose de si gros que ça ? Qu'est-ce que
c'est que la que ses références à des à
des dictateurs à des Donc je veux pas
faire de d'amalgam ou de simplification
de de
raccourcis
en escamotant en pleine différence, mais
on est
pour
d'une certaine manière et sur certains
éléments, on est aujourd'hui avec des
États qui ont des capacités de contrôle
beaucoup plus importants. que des
régimes dictatoriaux avaient. Je sais
qu'on a des des libertés formelles qui
sont plus importantes que dans ces
régimes. On peut parler de l'URSS,
la Chine, évidemment, l'Allemagne, c'est
l'Allemagne nazie évidemment est
l'exemple ultime généralement qu'on
parle de ça. Euh mais la Guestapo qui a
fait un travail qui a fait des dégâts
terribles et qui a qui a entraîné la
mort de là,
il faut 24 heures là
de tant de personnes. Euh eux, ils
tiraient un tiroir, ils avaient des
fiches là.
et ils avaient des informateurs, ils ont
été super efficaces quand même avec ça.
Aujourd'hui, n'importe quel
fonctionnaire de l'État, il en sait il
peut en savoir beaucoup plus sur vous et
sur moi que des agents de la GAPO à
l'époque et ils s'en servent déjà de ces
informations-là.
Euh et je parle même pas des caméras de
surveillance et euh et et de
reconnaissance faciale et de et de tout
ça. C'est incroyable ce que les États
ont. Et moi, j'ai des amis qui sont
super fiers quand le nouveau téléphone
cellulaire, comme je dit tout à l'heure,
j'ai pas de téléphone cellulaire, mais
j'ai des amis qui étaient super fiers
parce que leur leur téléphone
cellulaire, leur nouveau modèle, le mot
de passe était remplacé par leur
empreinte digitale.
J'ai dit "Attends,
tu tu donnes ton emprint à ton
ordinateur puis tu es super fier." J'ai
dit, "Tu es complètement malade toi."
Comme
il y a 10 15 ans, l'emprunt digitale,
c'était ce qu'on pas ce qu'on avait plus
précieux, ça veut rien dire. Mais on
donnait notre empreinte digitale qu'on
était obligé parce qu'on était accusé de
quelque chose. On allait donner notre
empreinte digitale à la police et
c'était on était découragé parce qu'à
partir de là on était traçable partout
partout par la police quoi. Mais
maintenant les gens ils pensent que
c'est une manière de sécuriser leur leur
téléphone.
C'est une soumission qu'on sentit. Ben
surtout beaucoup de naïveté et d'un
enthousiasme abérrant et donc
c'est foutu hein. Donc donc le le votre
prochain Kaiser là qui va s'appeler
Dupont euh Kaiser Duupont se fait bien
il il
va avoir tellement d'outils sous la
main, ça va être ça va être ça va être
un désastre. Mais est-ce que
mais est-ce que c'est ça qui nous attend
ça ? Je sais pas parce que quand on dit
dans toutes les époques où ça va mal, il
y a il y a une dérive autoritaire. C'est
un peu ça la théorie et que c'est un
appel du peuple d'avoir d'avoir Mais en
fait si on regarde bien malheureusement
c'est une histoire tragique mais ce
qu'on regarde bien c'est qu'en fait
c'est rarement 90 ou 80 % de la
population qui veut un dictateur
autoritaire. Généralement dans les
moments de grosses crise, il y a aussi
des forces contestatrices qui sont
beaucoup plus appelons ça libertaires ou
égalitaires. Appons appelons ça comme
ça. Le problème c'est qu'elles perdent
souvent.
Il y a combien de pourcentage il y a
c'était combien le le pourcentage de
résistants pendant la guerre 3945 en
France ? C'était quoi ça ?
Autodéclaré ou ou réel ? Ben en 45, ils
étaient beaucoup
mais en 42 ils étaient ils étaient moins
nombreux. Euh oui mais ça c'est pas
juste parce que vous et moi, on sait pas
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait fait dans cette
situation là. On sait qu'en Yugoslavie,
vous me regardez avec des yeux, vous
vous savez peut-être, moi je je moi je
me serais caché peut-être, je sais pas
si j'aurais été euh mais en Yougoslavie,
il y en avait beaucoup. Il y avait des
pays où il y en avait plein. Il y en
avait des pays où il y en avait moins.
Il y a des pays où ça a pris plus de
temps s'organiser, d'autres moins,
d'autres et cetera. On fait quoi là ?
Et euh et donc euh
et donc
et donc il faut pas être purement
pessimiste. Il va nécessairement, on
sait pas ce qui va arriver. Moi je sais
pas en tout cas, peut-être vous vous le
savez mais moi je le sais pas. Et c'est
certain qu'il va avoir des gens qui vont
demander un régime plus autoritaire. Il
y en a déjà qui le demandent puis il y
en a qui le demandaient hier déjà. Donc
il va toujours avoir des gens qui
veulent un régime plus autoritaire. Il y
a des gens qui ont des avantages avir un
régime plus autoritaire. Puis il y a des
gens qui ont un espoir qu'un régime plus
autoritaire va régler des problèmes
comme des gens qui réclament un pouvoir
à la Poutine en France. Oui, par
exemple. Et c'est surtout qu'il y a des
gens qui sont persuadés qu'un régime
autoritaire c'est pas grave parce que
ell elles n'ont rien à se reprocher. Ça
c'est comme pour les caméras de
surveillance. On s'en fout qu'il y a des
caméras de surveillance. Moi, je ne fais
pas d'acte criminel. Donc en fait, il
pourrait y avoir des caméras de
surveillance dans ma salle de bain, ça
changerait absolument rien. Ça serait
même cool parce que si quelqu'un vient
m'étrangler, ben au moins, on pourrait
le retracer. Donc, il y a toujours ces
personnesl un peu naïves qui disent
"Donnons tous les pouvoirs à l'État
parce que de toute façon, moi je suis un
bon citoyen, j'ai rien à m'approcher et
cetera. C'est pour les autres qu'il faut
qu'il faut contrôler." Mais comme je
dis, je répète, je suis désolé, mais à
chaque fois dans ces moments
historiques, j'ai aussi vu des gens qui
étaient du côté de la résistance ou de
la contestation dans des propositions
plus égalitaires. Mais comme je l'ai
dit, c'est généralement une histoire
tragique. Généralement, ces gens-là
perdent, mais moi, c'est à ces courants
là que je m'identifie.
Euh, vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté.
Euh,
au thématique générale,
open bar.
Ben déjà si les gens veulent aller voir
là j'y pense parce qu'on vient d'en
parler le livre de Peter Gouderlous aux
éditions libres
dont malheureusement c'est un peu bête
parce que j'ai écris la préfet je me
rappelle pas du exact en français mais
c'est je pense c'est comment la non
violence protège l'état je pense
peut-être on peut le mettre sur le site
je sais pas comment euh ça c'est bien
pour et là c'est vraiment influencé
parce que la dernière question sur la
résistance il y a Mark Bray qui est un
américain qui vient de dont son livre
vient d'être traduit euh tout récemment
euh ça s'appelle les antifas, donc c'est
sur le les mouvements antifascistes. Et
lui en fait, justement sur la question
qu'on vient de se que vous venez de me
poser, il a euh il a en fait intervivé
des dizaines et des dizaines de
militants antifascistes euh en France,
aux États-Unis, en Angleterre et
ailleurs. Et surtout ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est qu'il fait en fait
l'histoire du mouvement antifasciste
depuis les années 10 20 en France, aux
États-Unis, il donne des il y a des
histoires
je pense c'est Mark M a R K BR B R A Y
mais il faudrait vérifier et c'est je
pense c'est Antif aux éditions Luxe qui
est une maison d'édition québécoise.
Désolé pour mon capital nationalisme
éditorial. Euh 3è
un petit 3e. Là je suis euh j'ai le
cerveau en embau. Euh qu'est-ce que j'ai
lu ? Euh
si les gens veulent se s'initier
peut-être pour la France, ça peut être
euh un une façon de d'élargir les
horizons. C'est peut-être plus costaud
en terme euh théorique et euh et et
conceptuel et peut-être plus éloigné de
vos préoccupations. Mais moi, j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment fascinant. C'est un
un autochtone de la nation d'îné au euh
à Yellow Knife
qui s'écrit
euh Glenn Cultard.
Euh Glenn Cultard et qui a publié un
livre qui vient d'être traduit aussi en
français. Je suis désolé, c'est encore
la même maison d'édition euh mais c'est
euh Poau Rouge Masque Blanc et euh il
propose une réinterprétation
euh critique d'ailleurs euh évidemment
de tout le processus de colonisation euh
de dépossession des terres. il est en
débat avec les marxistes entre autres et
il essaie d'expliquer que euh la
question de la dépossession des terres
des Amériques par les puissances
coloniales, y compris la France
d'ailleurs, l'Angleterre, l'Espagne, le
Portugal et cetera. au début d'ailleurs
des puissances monarchistes mais avec
des visées précapitalistes puis après ça
des entreprises privées.
Il faut l'analyser pas seulement d'un
point de vue marxiste comme la création
disons d'un d'un sorte de
sous-prolétariat autochtone qui
travaille dans des dans des boulots
médiocres. Mais en fait c'est la capture
des terres. C'est c'est la capture
concrète des terres qui suit en fait des
processus précapitalistes en Europe où
on a on a on a privatiser le commun, on
a dépossédé les communautés paysanes
d'Europe de des terres communales. Donc
il s'est passé la même chose à très
grande échelle dans les Amériques et que
ça c'est le fondement de la logique du
système capitaliste, impérialiste,
colonial dans les Amériques, c'est la
dépossession des terres comme lieu
évidemment de vie. euh lieu de de vie,
pas de survie, de vie. Euh et c'est pour
ça que les en dans les Amériques, les
luttes des communautés autochtones et
très souvent lié à la c'est les c'est
des luttes c'est des luttes pour la
terre, c'est des luttes pour le pour le
territoire. Et Glenn Colti, ce qui est
intéressant, c'est qu'il ce que je
trouve intéressant, c'est que non
seulement il débat avec les marxistes,
mais il réinterprète Franz Fanon euh
entre autres au sujet, mais il
l'applique à l'Amérique euh et il est
très à l'écoute des mobilisations
autochtones actuelles des 10, 15, 20
dernières années. pour les personnes qui
nous écoutent qui ont peu de
connaissance sur ce qui se passe en
terme de mobilisation sociale,
mobilisation contestataire,
anticapitaliste aussi, mais très
critique de l'État colonial évidemment
et anticolonial dans les Amériques. Le
livre de Glen Cult est vraiment
extraordinaire.
Je vais vous poser une dernière question
qui n'est pas une question qui est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer sur
internet,
quelque chose d'impérissable.
Il faut pas la lancer à la mer la
bouteille. Il y a d'autres cibles.
Un message
euh
on lâche rien.
On lâche rien.
On essaye et on fait attention à nous, à
nos proches, aux autres.
Francis, merci.
Merci à vous vraiment beaucoup.
Coup.
[Musique]